Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir haben auch Geschichten, da werden Spieler geholt, die sind dann drei Monate wieder weg, weil sie nicht richtig betreut worden sind. Die kommen da geführt aus 300 Kilometern Entfernung und sind dann wieder weg. Dann muss man die schon nehmen und sagen, okay, wir haben quasi einen Auftrag, wir holen diesen jungen Menschen, keinen Spieler, sondern als Mensch und wir haben den Ausbildungsauftrag. Das ist nicht die Aufgabe des Altsjugendtrainers, die eigenen Referenzen abzubilden, sondern jeden Spieler, der Talent hat, so gut zu entwickeln, wie es geht. Und das ist schon noch ein Problem.
Aber das gehört zu diesem Gesamtbild dazu. Ja, jetzt sind wir 2014 Weltmeister. Das sind unsere Spieler. Das ist unser NRZ-Jahrgang. Das stimmt nur zur Hälfte, wenn überhaupt.
Ich begrüße euch sehr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zu Tribünengespräch Nummer 50. Wir haben heute eine Dreierrunde hier, also drei Gäste plus mich. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.soschl. Viel wichtiger ist, wer hier sonst noch ist. Zum einen sind zwei junge Herren zugeschaltet aus Paderborn. Zum einen Marius von Cysewski, erst 23 Jahre alt, auch gebürtig aus Paderborn. Hallo Marius. Schön, dass du hier bist und uns auch in voller Lautstärke hören kannst. Und ebenfalls hier ist Alexander Schulte, 24 Jahre aus Ottendorf-Okrilla bei Dresden. Hallo Alex. Und dann noch eine bekannte Stimme des Rasenfunks, der Ed Knallgöwer auf Twitter. Stefan Rommel ist hier aus seinem dunklen Zuhause. Schön, dass ihr drei hier seid. Über was wir genau sprechen wollen und so weiter, das werde ich gleich alles noch erklären. Vorher muss ich aber natürlich auch noch zwei, drei Worte zum Rasenfunk selber verlieren. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir tun, finanziert sich ausschließlich über eure Unterstützung, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und so ein Tribünengespräch könnte hier auch ein Anlass sein, uns zu unterstützen. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club erfahrt ihr das. Und an dieser Stelle danke ich Jasper, Fabian Sauerland, Purple Passion, Marlis, Stories und Frank, den sie alle unterstützen uns nicht nur, sondern haben sich auch als SupporterInnen registriert. Und dementsprechend konnte ich sie jetzt hier vorlesen. Und mit eurer Unterstützung finanzieren wir in dieser Saison auch noch etwas Besonderes. Wir schicken eine eigene Reporterin zur Frauen-WM nach Australien und Neuseeland. Also mindestens noch ein weiterer guter Grund, den Rasenfunk zu unterstützen. Jeder Betrag hilft. Bitte tut es. Und dann möchte ich euch noch kurz erklären, weil ich weiß, dass die Tribünengespräche auch noch Jahre später gehört werden. Was es sonst noch so im Rasenfunk gibt, ihr bekommt im Grunde inzwischen fast alles, was man so haben kann. Also wir machen Sendungen in der Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga der Frauen und der Männer. Wir machen Sendungen zum europäischen Männerfußball, das ist im Kurzpass der Fall, zur zweiten Männer Bundesliga und eben Tribünengespräche wie diese hier, in dem wir uns ein Thema ausführlich widmen wollen. Und genau das wollen wir jetzt tun. Wir finden uns hier zusammen anlässlich eines Buches, das herauskommt. Und zwar am 6. Mai erscheint die Jahrtausendtalente, wie zwei junge Fußballer ihren großen Traum lebten, die wahre Geschichte von zwei Jugend-Nationalspielern. Aufgeschrieben von Alex Rack, 240 Seiten, 18 Euro erschienen bei EGEL Sports. Und zwei Jahrtausendtalente sind jetzt auch hier in dieser Runde. Ihr müsst jetzt raten, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wer es ist. Malius und Alex, ihr seid damit gemeint. Wie ist das überhaupt, wenn man als Jahrtausendtalent bezeichnet wird?
Geht gar nicht.
Weil sonst, ich hätte gar nicht mitfahren können. Hätte ich irgendwie, hätte meine Mutter oder mein Vater mich nicht nach der Schule zum Treffpunkt fahren können. Ich hatte da bis 20 vor vier Viertel vor vier Schule. Um vier, kurz nach vier war Abfahrt nach Dortmund. Ich hätte da ja gar nicht hinkommen können, so schnell. Also wäre schon allein deswegen unmöglich geworden. Und das ist definitiv, die Vereine versuchen ja wirklich viel mit Zügen, mit Fahrdiensten vom Bahnhof und so weg, auch mit dem Abholen. Aber das schließt definitiv einige aus, die nicht diese Möglichkeit haben, dass die Eltern oder sonst irgendwer aus der Familie da so hintersteht und das mal eben so machen kann. Ja, keine Frage. Auf jeden Fall. Bei mir war die Extremphase dieser, gibt den ganz berühmten Dienstag, wenn ich auch nicht vergesse, war fünfte Klasse der Dienstag, 7.15 Uhr auf dem Platz stehen, dann 11.40 Uhr Unterricht, bis 17.30 Uhr, 18.30 Uhr wieder Training und dann bis 21 Uhr gehst du wieder durch die Zimmertür in dein Zimmer rein. Also dann geht es quasi 6.30 Uhr, geht es außer Haus. Und da hatte ich auch ganz tolle Eltern. Meine Schwester war auch gar nicht so untalentiert im Wasser. Also die war auch dann an der Sportschule Schwimmerin und dann Spieler-Triathletin, die war dann für mein Glück quasi auch auf dem Internat. Deswegen konnten meine Eltern sich ein bisschen auch auf mich da fokussieren, was die Fahrerei angeht. Aber die sah dann so aus, morgens dann zu diesem Frühtraining hingefahren, zwischen der Schule und dem Training nochmal kurz nach Hause was essen, weil das ging einfach nicht so gut. Und dann natürlich abends wieder abholen. Also das war, wie Marius sagt, es ist möglich. Es geht ja darum, die Talente auch dazu fördern in dem Sinne. Die Nachwuchsleistungszentren schaffen das auch ganz gut, die geben sich da super Mühe. Aber es fängt ja auch damit an, was auf dem Frühstückstisch zu haben, abgeholt zu werden vielleicht, abends was Gutes zu essen kriegen. Wenn man das nicht hat, wenn die Eltern vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, Nachtschicht haben oder so, wenn die solche Jobs haben, das macht es auf jeden Fall schwerer. Und da hatten wir auch das große Glück, dass meine Eltern auch selbstständig gewesen sind. Sie sind immer noch zu der Zeit, dass man da Unterstützung hatte, einfach auch zeitlich, also allein mit Fahr, mit einem Bus oder so, wäre das bei mir auch alles zeitlich ganz viel schwerer geworden.
Geld, also Armut ist immer noch der größte diskriminierende Faktor in Deutschland und nur kleines Gedankenexperiment. Wie viele Profi-Fußballerinnen kennt ihr die von Alleinerziehenden Mütter zum Beispiel großgezogen wurden? Das ist ja eine riesige Bevölkerungsschicht, die es gibt. Man muss das auch nicht problematisieren, weil ich persönlich finde, es muss nicht immer alles in den Leistungssport hineinführen. Das ist eigentlich so eine Grundthese, die ich habe. Aber man sollte eben auch nicht den Fehler machen, zu behaupten, jetzt würde schon jeder gleich gefördert. Das ist nicht so. Es gibt unterschiedliche Startvoraussetzungen. Für manche Menschen wäre ein solcher Alltag völlig undenkbar, einfach nicht umsetzbar. Und ich finde, der zweite Aspekt, der da noch mit drauf kommt, ist, wir werden heute, glaube ich, noch direkt und indirekt viel über Druck sprechen, der auch in diesem System ist, auf allen Akteuren, auf den Eltern, auf den Trainern, auf den SpielerInnen. Und auch solche Alltagsgestaltungen führen da Druck zu. Also zum einen, weil es extrem schwierig ist, neben all dem Ganzen noch eine schulische Ausbildung zu Ende zu bringen. Ich meine, du hast da gesagt, gerade der berühmte Dienstag, da hast du die Hausaufgaben gar nicht erwähnt. Ich vermute aber, du wirst auch Hausaufgaben gehabt haben.
Weniger hat es so gekriegt, die Schule. Da konnte man hingehen, mit Unterschriften usw. sagen, der Lehrgang ist da und da. Ich bin da nicht da. Dann wurde auch nicht irgendwie Druck gemacht, dass man mal einen Fehltag hat oder so. Sondern dann wurde geguckt, wie kriegt man dich mit Hausaufgaben gut gefüllt in der Zeit. Da wird auch mal gleichzeitig in den Auge zugedrückt, wenn man mal die Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht hat. Aber es gab echt. Ich hatte in Paderborn schon ein akutes Hausaufgabe. Ich bin morgens früh raus, bin zur Schule, dann, wie ich eben gesagt habe, 20 vor 4, Viertel vor 4 aus der Schule fertig. Meine Mutter hat mich abgeholt, irgendwie ganz schnell zum Frankfurter Weg, dann nach Dortmund. Ich habe weder auf der Fahrt nach Dortmund Hausaufgaben gemacht, noch abends, als ich dann um halb 10, 10 Uhr mit Essen und einem fertig war, habe ich mich auch nicht mehr hingesetzt. Das war natürlich ein bisschen schwieriger alles da, weil ich sage mal, das war ein ganz normales Gymnasium. Und da war jetzt nicht so das Verständnis so riesig, für Sachen, die dann da so abgehen. Und irgendwie habe ich mich da auch durchgemogelt, immer, das hat schon funktioniert. Aber ich sage mal, wenn man sich jetzt, wenn man wirklich ambitioniert seine Hausaufgaben in dem Alter hätte machen wollen, wäre das dann nochmal nach 22 Uhr dran gewesen. Hätte das, wäre der Deal gewesen, wenn man das hätte machen wollen.
Und es wäre ja aber vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, Hausaufgaben zu machen, weil wir schaffen ja nur wenige Prozent in den Profifußball.
Definitiv. Es wird ja mal salopp gesagt, der Plan B. Aber man sagt immer, ja, es gibt den Plan B, machen wir den Plan B, ein bisschen Schule. Wir nutzen mal die Plattform, die wir haben, nehmt den Plan B bitte nicht, einfach nur so locker.
Es will bloß einer zugeben, dass es der Plan A ist.
Also man sagt immer, man will, man hat die Scheuklappen auf und sagt, ich bin der eine oder ich bin das eine Bruder, ich gehöre zu den ein Prozent, die Profis werden. Wir haben ganz viele Geschichten, wo es auch mal am letzten Punkt auch nicht zur Karriere gereicht hat, auf Verletzungen zum Beispiel zurückzuführen. Das ist ganz gut, wenn man die Schule, was in der Tasche hat, was gut ist.
Und jetzt auch, ohne jetzt ein großes Fass aufmachen zu wollen, aber alles, was wir jetzt die letzten 10 Minuten gehört haben, weist ja schon darauf hin, was es für große Probleme geben kann. Und jetzt stellen wir es sich mal vor, Kinder, die heute 10, 11, 12 sind, die überlegen, ob sie vielleicht so einen Schritt gehen sollen, ob sie diese ganzen Entbehrungen auf sich nehmen sollen, die Eltern mit dazu und so weiter. Das sind aber alles Kinder, die jetzt 2 bis 2, 5 Jahre quasi kaum oder nur teilweise Schule hatten wegen Corona. Und jetzt kommt es noch on top, gerade Kinder, die jetzt in der fünften Klasse zum Beispiel sind, die in diesem Übergang sind auf eine weiterführende Schule, die 2 Jahre lang – ich sage das mal überspitzt – nichts gelernt haben in der Schule. Die sollen jetzt auf einer anderen Schule sich zurechtfinden, die sollen den Verein wechseln, die sollen vielleicht sogar in ein Leistungszentrum gehen. Sorry, das kann niemals funktionieren, tut mir leid.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz, ganz schwieriger Punkt für die.
Definitiv.
Wir haben es ja nicht erlebt, aber wir mussten es zum Glück nicht so erleben. Wir waren als Corona-Beiher eigentlich schon über 18. Wir haben das ja nicht erleiden müssen, so extrem. Aber für die muss ich mir auch ganz, ganz, ganz hart vorstellen, so einen großen Schritt. Vor 2, 5 Jahren konnte es nichts richtig machen, da hast du deine Mitschüler nie gesehen. Manche haben ihre Mitschüler mit Maske kennengelernt und haben die wahrscheinlich vor einem Jahr das erste Mal richtig mit Gesicht gesehen und dann kommen noch solche. Oder wenn man dann so einen Schritt wagen möchte, definitiv noch mal ein ganz, ganz großes Handicap, was die haben, hast du komplett recht.
Und dann haben wir ja auch die Situation, dass man ja dennoch alles, also man möchte es ja genauso haben. Man hat diesen großen Traum, man, man, und das ist ja auch schön. Man möchte ja auch Kindern jetzt nicht sagen, also es gibt bestimmt genügend Eltern, die ihren Kindern das verbieten und sagen, nein, es tut mir leid, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, das kann für dich kein Weg sein. Aber natürlich gibt es auch die Eltern, eure Eltern ja auch, die das unterstützt haben und die selbst, wenn sie selber zurückhaltend sind und das vielleicht auch realistisch sehen, es schaffen nur ein Prozent aller Menschen in den Profifußball, davon leben zu können und vielleicht auch so, dass man ausgesorgt hat am Ende der Karriere, wenn der Körper kaputt ist, das können noch weniger als nur ein Prozent. Das weiß man alles und dennoch lässt man sich dann auf diesen Alltag ein. Man möchte ja auch sein Kind fördern, man sieht, dass das Kind Spaß daran hat oder der Jugendliche dann. Und dann wird man aber, glaube ich, selbst Teil dieses Systems in dem Sinne, dass diese ganz harte Selektion, die es gibt, die betrifft, glaube ich, die Eltern genauso wie die Kinder und führt ja auch zu unheimlich viel Reizpunkten in diesem System. Ich habe mal einen O-Ton mitgebracht von Prof. Dr. Arne Güllich von der rheinland-pfälzischen TU Kaiserslautern Landau. Der war zu Gast in einem Beitrag von Sport Insight über Jugendfußball und der hat mal Studien zitiert, was die Fluktuation jetzt dann in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren angeht, aber das gibt einen ganz guten Eindruck. Ich spiele das mal kurz ein.
Die Nachwuchsleistungszentren oder international dann Centers of Excellence oder Youth Academies haben eine jährliche Auffrischungsrate von 29%. Was heißt das? In jedem Kader sind in einer folgenden Saison 29% der vorigen Saison nicht mehr dabei, sondern werden durch andere ausgetauscht.
Und das wollte ich eben nochmal hier einspielen. Ist sowieso eine empfehlenswerte Doku. Da wird auch nochmal ein bisschen anderer Fokus gelegt als hier im Tribünengespräch, um einfach nur zu verdeutlichen. Bei all dem, was man da auf sich nimmt und was man da an Stress und so weiter hat, ist es dennoch so, dass nach drei Jahren kennt sich keiner mehr im Kader, denn es wurde einmal ausgetauscht. Wie habt ihr denn das wahrgenommen, dass ihr ab einem gewissen Punkt – wahrscheinlich müsst ihr jetzt sagen, wann das so anfängt, vielleicht so 14, 15, 16 – da hat man ja auch dann das Gefühl, okay, ich kann es vielleicht schaffen. Und dann nimmt man das ja noch viel, viel extremer wahr. Es kann auch in jedem Frühjahr Schluss sein. Also Thomas Hitzesberger hat später mal gesagt – und über den haben damals die Leute gesagt, dass der immer herausragend war in seiner Generation – der hat gesagt, dass er in jedem Frühling das Gefühl hatte, jetzt ist für mich Schluss, ich werde aussortiert. Wie habt ihr das erlebt und ab wann hat das begonnen?
Also ich habe – oder bei mir war der Cut ja mit vom, sag ich mal, Dorfein Heide, dann zu U14 nach Dortmund, das war ja ein Riesensprung erstmal. Und für mich ist da ja auch wirklich die Reise losgegangen. Ich hatte dann das große Glück, dass ich in meinem ersten U14-Jahr direkt nach ein paar Monaten einen Vierjahresvertrag angeboten bekommen habe von Dortmund. Das heißt, ich wusste, ok, den habe ich unterschrieben, da war ich schon mal einigermaßen fest im Satte. Erstmal, weil die Leistung auch gut war, war das zu dem Zeitpunkt erstmal alles gut. Aber dieser Wechsel an Spielern, den habe ich schon vor allem auch in der U14 und U15 als relativ extrem wahrgenommen, weil da echt nochmal, worüber wir eben gesprochen haben, so da ist einer körperlich auf einmal in seinem zweiten Jahr dann in der U15 nochmal einen richtigen Schritt gemacht. Und plötzlich war der genauso auf dem Level von allen anderen, konnte aber schon besser Fußball spielen vorher und war dann dabei. Und da sind einige, die vielleicht vorher schon ein bisschen besser waren, körperlich ein bisschen besser waren, sondern rausgefallen zu U16. Und dann habe ich, so wie ich das im Kopf habe, U16, U17, U19, gab es immer einen Kern der Mannschaft, der ist definitiv geblieben. Und weil wir halt bei Dortmund waren, wurde sehr viel dazu gekauft. Also ich hatte jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass da mega viele weggebrochen sind, sondern der Kader wurde einfach größer. Die haben einfach – ist natürlich mal ein, zwei weg oder mal gewechselt. Aber im Prinzip war der Kern der Mannschaft da und zum Beispiel wir hatten das in meinem U16-Jahr. Haben die zwei aus Freiburg geholt, einen aus Frankfurt, einen aus Hamburg, Düsseldorf, Essen. Guck mal, das habe ich sogar aus dem Stil gegriffen. Die auf jeden Fall. Also einmal in Deutschland hier zu U16, 7, 8 Mann dazu gepackt. So und dann aber aus unserem U15-Jahrgang sind dann gar nicht mehr so viele abgehauen. Zu U17 haben sie dann noch einen aus Kaiserslautern geholt und zu U19 haben sie dann auch noch in England und so eingekauft. Also der Kader ist einfach immer größer geworden. Aber jetzt nicht, weil viele weggegangen sind, sondern einfach, weil es schön dazu gekauft wurde. Und die haben gesagt, dass ja, solange wir guter auf dem Platz haben und wir gewinnen, war das ja in Ordnung. Das habe ich so wahrgenommen, dass einfach der Kader immer größer wurde. Das Schwunzeln, wo du sagst, nach der U15 zur U16 habt ihr so viel eingekauft. Wir haben damals als U16 gegen euch gespielt, in der U15. Und da hatten wir als U16 quasi gesagt, oh die U15, wir haben euch gegen euch gewonnen. Und wir haben halt so gesagt, so spielerisch. Und ich glaube, den Verantwortlichen bei Dortmund ist auch aufgefallen, wir müssen vielleicht mal ein bisschen die Schrauben anziehen bei diesem Jahrgang. Wir müssen mal ein bisschen aufstoppen. Und das hat man ja gesehen. Dann haben wir nämlich nochmal gegen die gespielt, als U17 gegen die U16. Und da war das ein ganz anderes Gesicht. Natürlich auch mit denen neu zu gingen. Wenn du natürlich da 7, 8 Spieler quasi deutschlandweit dazuholst, war das ganz lustig anzusehen. Weil da haben wir dann auf jeden Fall an Qualität dazugeholt.
Gleichzeitig ist das ja aber ein Aussortieren durch die Hintertür, Stefan. Wenn der Kader immer größer wird, bedeutet es ja weniger Spielzeit.
Naja, also hier treffen aus meiner Sicht zwei Welten aufeinander. Wir wollen gute Spieler zu sehr guten Spieler zu tollen Spieler zu Profi-Spielern machen. Also wir heißen es in dem Fall jedes NLZ. Jeder Verein hat für sich diese Vision, das so zu machen. Und dann muss ich dem Ganzen aber einen gewissen Ausbildungskarakter überstücken, der immer zählen muss. Aus meiner Sicht. Der muss immer zählen. Für jeden Spieler muss der zählen. Jede Saison. Und wir haben jetzt aber bei euren beiden Ausführungen immer wieder gehört, muss man Spiele gewinnen, muss man besser werden, holt man Spieler dazu. Dann wird es gibt diesen Deutschland-NLZ-Kreislauf. Marius hat jetzt irgendwie zehn Spieler aufgeführt, die aus anderen NLZ nach Dortmund kommen. Und ich verstehe dann einfach nicht, also ich verstehe das schon. Warum? Weil die eben diesen gewinnsportlichen Anreiz diesen permanent hinterherjagen. Aber der Ausbildungskarakter rückt da immer wieder in den Hintergrund. Immer wieder. Und was denkt sich so ein Spieler wie Marius, der dann in der U17 ist, und der sieht dann, ach, beim ersten Training nach der Sommerpause, da sind jetzt schon wieder sechs, sieben neue dabei. Nachher sind sogar welche aus Frankreich dabei und aus Dänemark und aus England. Und aus Kanada. Weiß der Geier woher? Ja, was heißt das denn jetzt für mich? Bin ich jetzt nicht mehr gut genug? Oder warum sind die jetzt hier? Was soll das? Warum spielt das einer aus Freiburg? Okay, der soll dann Freiburg spielen. Also wo ist da der Punkt? Dieses Hin- und Hergeschiebe von Talenten, von einem NLZ zum anderen. Dieses Hopping, das ist für mich nicht immer nachvollziehbar. Vor zwei Wochen war das, war der Hermann Hummels im Blickpunkt Sport in Bayern 3. Und hat dann erzählt, wie er für sich selber, also wie es von einem Sinn ist, bei sich selbst. Früher war das für ihn auch noch völlig normal, so vor 15, 20 Jahren, sowas zu machen, sowas zu verfolgen in seiner Funktion beim FC Bayern. Mittlerweile sagt er halt auch so. Also eigentlich ist das totaler Bullshit. Wenn einer aus dem NLZ in Fürth nach Unterhagen geht und von Unterhagen zu 60, um das 60 zum FC Heidenheim, dann hat er viel NLZ gesehen, da ist er 17 Jahre alt. Was soll das?
Ich glaube, du wolltest anschließen. Ich hätte noch eine kleine Anekdote zu Hermann Hummels. Hermann Hummels war nämlich da ja auch Berater ja. Und der hat auch in der U14 dann bei meinem Vater angerufen und hat mal nachgefragt, wie es aussieht. Und mit Hermann Hummels daßen wir auf der Rückreise als Familie in München im Hotel, nachdem Deutschland Weltmeister geworden ist. Und er hat uns ein paar nette Geschichten über die Rio-Nacht erzählt, der Weltmeister von 2014. Das war sehr interessant. Wollte ich mal nur kurz hier einwerfen zu Hermann Hummels. Ich hätte bei dem anderen, was du gerade gesagt hast, direkt angeschlossen, Stefan, mit dem Hopping quasi. Aus Spielersicht – und das schließt ja vielleicht auch nochmal in die Frage von Max am Anfang mit diesem Aussieben, wie das aus Sicht der Spieler ist. Da kann ich ja nur von mir persönlich sprechen. Ich habe es relativ früh gemerkt, Kicken macht dir Spaß, aber du schießt auch gut Tore. Du bist ganz gut dabei. Du kriegst in den Turnieren, ganz oft, den ich dabei war, bester Torschütze, bester Spieler. Und man ist ja immer, man guckt, okay, man ist ja auch dann, man hat diesen Ehrgeiz, man will besser werden. Und man kommt auch nicht auf ein Niveau Junior im Bundesliga, wenn die Selbstmotivation nicht da ist. Also man will besser werden, man muss es selber wollen. Dann ist das ja bei uns immer so gewesen, wie weit dieser Gedanke, wie weit schafft man es? Also wo ist meine Grenze? Weil wir haben gerade gesagt oder darüber gesprochen, wir haben alle einen gemeinsamen Anfang. Jeder kennt, wie er zum Fußball angeschossen hat. Aber gleichzeitig weiß jeder Einzelne, der mal Fußball gespielt hat, wie er aufgehört hat. Also ich glaube, Max, du bist das beste Beispiel. Das sind ganz, ganz viele, die so schnell merken, das hört im Hobbyverein bei sich im Dorf schon auf. Das macht man so aus Spaß. Dann kennt man vielleicht einen, der zunächst größeren Dorf, zunächst größeren Ort wechselt. Mal gucken, wie weit der kommt. Und so ist das ja bei uns auch gewesen. Und wir hatten das Glück, dass wir immer die waren, die wie gesagt haben, wie hoch kommen wir quasi. Das war ja dann auch eine Herausforderung. Und das war dann schön. Ich habe gerade darüber gesprochen, die Kreisauswahl. Hey, du kriegst eine Einladung zur Kreisauswahl. Man freut sich, man gibt da Folge, dass man hat da Bock zu spielen. Komm zur Landesauswahl und so weiter. Und dann steigt man ja dann immer auf. Man weiß natürlich, dass man wegfallen kann, aber das war für uns ja quasi lange Zeit, das gehört ja dazu. Und es hat uns ja auch nicht betroffen in dem Sinne. Unser Ziel war ja dann, hat man uns mit sechs gefragt, wir wollen Fußballprofis werden, hat man uns mit zwölf gefragt, wir wollen Fußballprofis werden, und dann wurde das ja der Traum verfolgt. Und um das abschließend hier mit dem Hopping, da muss ich zum Beispiel sagen, ich finde das okay, dass das so ist, weil wir dürfen auch nicht, dass wir nicht, dass wir nicht, dass wir nicht vergessen, dass das Geschäft ist einfach so, dass da mit harten Bandagen gespielt wird, untereinander von den Vereinen. Und zum Beispiel, es, also ich verstehe zum Beispiel Dortmund hat den Anspruch, die besten Jugendspieler zu haben, und dadurch dann halt, wie zum Beispiel ein Sancho, wie man sie alle kennen, Brun Larsen, Pullisic, die dann aus der U19 hoch in den Profikader, und die schlagen dann meistens ein wie eine Bombe, beziehungsweise werden dann gut verkauft.
Die aber ja auch alle extern eingekauft wurden, oder?
Alle extern eingekauft, und da hat ja Dortmund auch den Anspruch, zum Beispiel jetzt mit dem Beispiel aus U16, dass sie sich dann die besten Spieler holen, ja. Zum Beispiel aus Kaiserslautern, aus Hamburg. Das gehört dazu, so ist die Realität. So ist es nun mal, wenn man dann Richtung Profi geht, man weiß, es ist dieser 1%, man weiß, dass der Verein die holt, aber dann schließt sich gleichzeitig an, was Stefan sagt, und da bin ich absolut bei dir, Stefan. Dann steht ja immer noch in der Jugend komischerweise der Erfolg im Vordergrund, also Meisterschaften gewinnen, Siege holen, darüber haben wir gesprochen, aber dann finde ich es paradox, genau da muss eigentlich, Naubisch, Stefan gesagt hat, immer noch die Ausbildung im Vordergrund stehen. Also es ist ja okay, wenn er den aus Hamburg holt, wenn man sich dazu entschließt, einen Spieler zu holen, sei es aus dem NLZ von Hamburg, weil er einfach so gut ist, weil Dortmund ihn unbedingt haben will, dann kann er den holen, aber dann muss er ihn auch besser machen wollen und nicht einfach mal so eben holen, das hat mir auch oft das Gefühl, dass Spieler einfach geholt worden sind und diese Ausbildung gar nicht so im Vordergrund stammt, sondern dass dann das Gewinn im Vordergrund steht und nicht den Spieler besser zu. Es spricht ja theoretisch nichts dagegen, wenn diese Spieler holen und Dortmund einen richtigen Plan mit denen hat, die richtig entwickeln will und von diesen sechs wird einer, zwei, richtig entwickelt sich richtig gut und wird Profi. So und da ist oft so der Verschleiß, würde ich es nennen, ziemlich hoch an Spielern, die geholt werden, die auch dann natürlich auf der anderen Seite ab und zu den Verein verlassen. Da schließe ich mich an, Stefan, dass ich dann eher so, also ich finde es gar nicht so schlimm, das ist nun mal so, dass die besten Vereine dann untereinander sich die Spieler holen. Wenn man aber die Verantwortung weiterhin hat auf die Spieler und weiß, man hat gerade jemanden aus Hamburg geholt und wir haben auch Geschichten, da werden Spieler geholt, die sind dann nach drei Monaten wieder weg, weil sie nicht richtig betreut worden sind, die kommen da gefühlt aus 300 Kilometern Entfernung und sind dann wieder weg, dann muss man die schon nehmen und sagen, okay, wir haben quasi einen Auftrag, wir holen diesen jungen Menschen, keinen Spieler, sondern als Mensch, und wir haben den Ausbildungsauftrag und da sind wir, drehen wir uns wieder, kriegen quasi den Kreis geschlossen und sagen, eigentlich macht es Sinn, die Ausbildung wieder in Vordergrund zu stellen, mündige Spieler rauszubringen, mündige Jugendliche, die mit 18 oder mit 17 das Internat oder das NLZ verlassen und einfach besser ausgebildete Spieler, da muss man nicht den Verschleiß so hoch haben. Aber Stefan, du hast ja eigentlich schon die Kernfrage gerade gestellt, das müssen die Vereine und das muss er auf der DFB sich entscheiden. Und diese Diskussion gibt es ja im Moment sehr extrem. Warum haben wir hier plötzlich nicht mehr so viele gute Spieler? Da ist ja wirklich die Frage in der Jugend, ist das Ziel, Meisterschaften zu gewinnen, Pokalsiege zu holen, der Beste zu sein, weil das, was Dortmund ja macht, mit diesen Jugend so gut zu gestalten, mit Spielern von extern, das funktioniert ja auch wirtschaftlich für die. Wir haben ja mit Sancho das erlebt, wie Alex gesagt hat, Pulisic, das hat ja funktioniert. Dortmund hat den Spieler ja nicht ausgebildet. Die haben den als Supertalent gekauft, der hat hier noch ein bisschen in der U19 gespielt und ist dann hoch. Für mich ist das keine Ausbildung. Das ist ein schlauer Transfer, aber das hat nichts mit Ausbildung zu tun. Und da ist in Summa die Frage, will der DFB, dass man wirklich sagt, ok, es ist wichtiger für uns in der Jugend, die Spieler auszubilden? Man soll ja jetzt nicht einfach sagen, wir spielen als C-Sieger egal, wir spielen nicht mehr Meisterschaften, weil es gibt keine Punkte mehr. Das ist ja auch Quatsch, man soll ja auch diese Siegermentalität entwickeln. Aber es ist halt, wie du gesagt hast, und da sehe ich auch so, es geht zu viel in der Jugend um die Meisterschaften, um den Erfolg des Vereins. Und zu wenig, um eigentlich die Spieler auszubilden. Und aus meiner Sicht ist das ein großes Problem, was wir haben.
Ich stelle mir noch eine Gegenfrage, wenn es gestartet ist. Ich verstehe das alles und ich verstehe die wirtschaftlichen Zwänge und dass man damit wahnsinnig viel Geld dann auch verdienen kann. Ich habe dir die Beispiele jetzt gerade schon genannt. Du kannst auch von C. Davis nehmen bei Bayern oder Musiala. Das ist im Prinzip dasselbe. Aber welche Daseinsberechtigung hat dann eine NLZ-Ausbildung unterhalb der U16 bei so einem Verein? Warum gehen die Vereine dann nicht einfach her und sagen, wir lassen sie einfach irgendwo in ihren Vereinen spielen. Die sind dann gut oder halt auch nicht gut genug. Wir kaufen ja so und so ab, wenn die 16, 15, die Grenze ist ja schwimmend, die gefühlt immer noch weiter nach unten, kaufen wir uns ja den Kader so und so zusammen. Es ist völlig wurscht, was da vorher passiert.
Absolut. Das ist der Punkt. Das habe ich ja versucht, so ein bisschen zu beantworten mit diesem Man muss. Es klingt dann immer ein bisschen verweichlicht. Man muss diesen bereit sein oder dieses Bewusstsein haben als Verein. Ich hole halt diese Person, ich hole den nicht als Spieler. Ich finde es auch im Nachhinein nicht schlimm, mit 14 zu Dortmund gewechselt zu sein. Aber es muss dem Verein bewusst sein, wenn wir diesen Schritt holen, den ich mit dem Vierjahresvertrag beispielsweise ausstatten, dass da auch wirklich der Plan ist, diese Vierjahre diesen Spieler weiter auszubilden und nicht mal diesen Vierjahresvertrag geben, um den quasi vier Jahre zu parken. Wo soll er schon hingehen? Er kickt gut oder wir schmeißen ihn nach vier Jahren raus. Da muss dann sein, wenn du die Spieler holst, unter der U16 beispielsweise, warum dann nicht wirklich dieses Projekt diesen Spieler über lange Sicht – ich habe mich entschieden, den zu holen – den auch wirklich auszubilden, auf allen Ebenen. Und dann sind wir wieder bei der Frage, wo sind unsere Spielertypen? Dann geht es genau darum, lasst die Leute sich dann entwickeln. Dann muss aber auch der Plan da sein und nicht einfach so die Jungs holen und dann so mal eben machen lassen. Weil dann ist genau der Punkt, Stefan, den du gesagt hast. Weil dann kann man eigentlich die Frage stellen, warum investiert ihr so viel in die U9 bis U16? Wie steht doch eigentlich da, wenn BVB anklopft bei der U17 von einem Spieler, der kommt? Dann bastelt euch eure U17 und U19 erst dann zurecht oder euer NLZ eigentlich.
Also es gibt ja valide Gründe dafür, das so zu machen. Aber ich sehe das ja jetzt selber hier bei Kindern, die 11, 12 sind, bei meinem Sohn zum Beispiel, der wie gesagt ein bisschen weg vom Schuss ist. Aber das finde ich nicht gut. Das muss ich ganz klar so sagen, wenn die dann Anfang mit 10 Jahren schon so in Richtung Leistungszentrum geschubst zu werden. Und ich sage aber, er lasst ihn doch jetzt hier bis er 12, 13 ist, bis er in der Schule angekommen ist, weiß, was das heißt, nicht drei, vier in der Schule zu haben, sondern zehn. Zweite Fremdsprache, das wisst ihr ja selber alles. Wenn er das alles schon mal mitgemacht hat und weiß, was auf ihn zukommt, dann kann er sich immer noch dafür entscheiden. Das sehe ich halt, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Da verstehe ich auch die NLZ nicht oder viele NLZ nicht, die da wirklich so so viel abgreifen und früh die Kinder schon holen, wo sie doch genau wissen, es wird im Regelfall so und so nicht so funktionieren, dass wir den jetzt hier neun Jahre lang begleiten und er dann einen Profivertrag unterschreibt und Zeit nur in der Regionalliga macht.
Das ist vielleicht noch mal ein guter Punkt, das zu sagen. Auch mit dem Buch, was wir geschrieben haben und mit den Sachen, die wir aufzeigen, wir kritisieren ja gar nicht, dass der Zustand, wie er jetzt ist, dass die Spieler holen, das ist BVB zum Beispiel, das ist ein AG, alles gut, die sind darauf aus, Geld zu verdienen und das ist auch vollkommen okay. Es ist auch vollkommen okay, dass nach wie vor ein Prozent der Spieler Profis werden. Das ist nun mal so. Wir sehen aber zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt darüber sprechen, wie man die Ausbildung verbessern könnte, du könntest viel besser, also viel mehr Spieler auch dann quasi hervorbringen, also auch dann verkaufen beispielsweise. Wir sagen ja gar nicht, oh Gott, holt die armen Spieler nicht und verkauft sie am besten nicht und so weiter. Wir stellen das alles ja nicht in Frage. Sondern warum verbessert man diese Struktur nicht? Weil dann profitieren alle. Dann profitiert der deutsche Fußball, dann profitiert der DFB, dann profitiert selbst der eigene Verein. Also wenn man mal guckt, wo BVB herkommt seit 2012, die kamen nur darüber, dass auf einmal junge Spieler quasi für geringes Geld eingekauft worden sind, dann unter Kloppen natürlich super aufgeblüht sind. Jeder profitiert davon. Manche Vereine wie Freiburg waren auch darüber angewiesen, lange Jahre sind sie jetzt immer wahrscheinlich noch, weil sie es einfach beibehalten. Gute Jugendarbeit und darüber zu kommen. Also es kann ja alles beibehalten werden, so wie es ist. Es ist auch so, wie es ist, auch okay. Die besten sollen dann auch schließlich nach oben kommen. Soll ja nicht jeder hier die Siegerurkunde bekommen und Profi werden. Nein, ist natürlich nicht so. Aber man könnte das einfach verbessern. Diese Umstände, die wir gerade angesprochen haben, diese Fragen gut beantworten, die du gerade gestellt hast, Stefan. Und dann kommen mehr und bessere Spieler in der 3. Liga an, 2. Liga, 1. Liga. Also da kann man den Schuh ja noch weiter umdrehen, wenn wir dann wieder dabei sind, wo wir sagen, ja, Frankreich zum Beispiel, wenn wir auf DFB-Ebene gucken, Frankreich freut sich, ja. Quasi dieses Sprungbrett, U19 Bundesliga ist ja extrem. Oder England, ja, das merkt man ja mittlerweile. Die Talente kommen rüber, werden hier dann zu Profis, ja, und werden dann, kommen sie entweder zurück in die Premier League, aber die spielen mindestens in der englischen Nationalmannschaft. Die freuen sich darüber. So und wo man dann auch auf lange Sicht denkt, haben wir auch uns geguckt, ja, die deutsche Meisterschaft ist jetzt wieder ganz ETPT-Off-Sky wird übertragen. Und jeder sagt, wow, es ist auch toll, dass so ein Fokus auf der Jugend liegt. Also bei mir war das noch nicht. Bei mir hat es gerade angefangen mit Sport 1 damals. Ist toll, dass sich die breite Bevölkerung viel darüber interessiert. Aber die U19 DFB hat sich nicht für die EM qualifiziert. Das vergisst man dann nebenbei. Da läuft dann schon viel schief, wo jeder sagt, das ist ein Aushängelschild des deutschen Fußballs, hier in Mainz gegen Dortmund zu gucken. Es ist auch. Aber vergesst nicht, dass man da vielleicht auch auf der Gesamtsicht nicht so gut dasteht. Dass man das eigentlich verbessern kann und dass man da auch eigentlich Nachholpotenzial hat. Und nicht dieses, ja das haben wir immer schon so gemacht. Das läuft auch so. Wir sind ja 2014 Weltmeister geworden. Das ist zehn Jahre her bald. Ja, also da muss man vielleicht mal ein bisschen einfach mal Sachen hinterfragen, vielleicht optimieren. Und dann kann man die Sachen, die Strukturen, die ja schon gut da sind, einfach verbessern.
Jetzt explodiert mein Kopf bei dir, weil ich tausend Sachen dazu sagen könnte. Aber das wird jetzt echt den Rahmen sprengen. Aber du sprichst echt eine wichtige Sache. 2014 war halt wieder mal so ein Kipppunkt, wo der DFB, wie er es vorher schon gemacht hat, in der Stunde des großen Erfolgs die Scheuklappen zugemacht hat und dann gar nichts mehr mitbekommen hat. Und es war schon vor der WM 2018 dann in Russland, war schon für Leute, die sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigen, ersichtlich, dass es schwierig werden die nächsten Jahre, weil links und rechts sind andere Verbände an Deutschland vorbeigezogen in der Nachwuchsausbildung. Und mein Indikator ist immer, wenn so ein kleines Land wie Belgien oder die Niederlande, wenn die auf einmal wieder ihre U-Mannschaften in die Endturniere bringen und Deutschland nicht, ich glaube, bei U19 ist es glaube ich von den letzten siebenmal, fünfmal gescheitert in der Quali, so eine Drehung, dann läuft etwas ganz gehörig schief, weil diese kleinen Verbände, die haben einfach nicht die Ressourcen, die wir haben, und die haben auch nicht das Geld, das der DFB damals zumindest noch hatte, also müssen sie andere kreative Lösungen finden. Und das können die viel besser als dieser riesen Tanker DFB, und da haben die einfach wahnsinnig geschlafen. Und jetzt gibt es Leute – und jetzt mache ich das fast doch auf – die wollen wirklich was verändern, die wollen reformieren, die wollen Sachen anders machen, auf verschiedensten Ebenen, beim Spieler, beim Trainer, bei der Wettbewerbsstruktur usw. Und dann gibt es aber 21 Landesverbände und 21 Landesverbandfürsten, von denen einige da einfach nicht mitziehen und die diese Dinge dann blockieren. Und das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig großes Problem für uns. Wahnsinnig groß. Deswegen dauert das immer. Wenn überhaupt mal was passiert, dauert es eeeewig, bis das Ingang gesetzt wird, bis es zurückgeht, bis es verabschiedet wird und dann, bis man sich so eindruggelt und nimmt nur das Thema Furninjo jetzt bei den Kleinsten bis zu 10 Jahren. Was das für ein Aufschrei ist, weil die jetzt Furninjo spielen, sollen zusätzlich – also es wird nichts gekillt und was anderes wird dafür platziert – sondern es sind zusätzliche Angebote, wo die – und die sind da. Das hat wirklich Hand und Fuß, das so zu machen, dass man das sowohl den klassischen Fußball mit 6 plus 1 gegen 6 plus 1 spielt auf dem E-Jugend-Feld, mit E-Jugend-Toren, mit dem Torwart usw. und als Paralleluniversum dazu Furninjo einführt, wo die Kinder einfach 70 Ballkontakte haben in einer Viertelstunde und nicht in der Gegend rumstehen und die Gänseblümien aus dem Rasen rausblicken. Ja, das verstehen wir auch.
Was ja Spanien auch schon seit über 20 Jahren macht, glaube ich, Furninjo. Also es ist ja nicht mal neu.
Marius hat das immer ganz toll gesagt.
Marius hat das immer ganz toll gesagt. Dann muss sich jemand überschwungseln, wenn du genauso mit Belgien ansprichst. Der Spruch ist einfach immer, wir haben es mal ein bisschen mathematischer aus. Einfach, wenn man mal wirklich dieses rationale Denken hat. Nehmen wir das Land Belgien, ja, einfach Einwohner zahlenmäßig. Ja, wie kriegen, es kann doch nicht sein, dass man, dass so ein kleines Land, dass man, wie du sagst, einen Stein wirft, über der Grenze ist und auf einmal können die besser kicken als wir. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass hier das Talent weniger ist. Also einfach von dem, was man in die Wiege gelegt bekommt. Oder in Portugal, die sind einwohnerzahltechnisch, ressourcentechnisch genau das, was du sagst. Stefan ist da nicht vorhanden wie in Deutschland. Aber auf einmal, wie du immer so schon sagst, gibt es in Deutschland keinen, keinen Dribbler? Gibt es nur Siala beispielsweise nur einmal? So das glauben wir nicht. Es liegt einfach daran, wie geht man mit den Ressourcen um, die man hat? Und die machen das ganz anders. Und es ist schön, dass Stefan das nämlich gesagt hat, weil ich glaube, 2014 hat man die Früchte ernten können, die man da bis dahin gut gemacht hat. Das sind ja dann die Schweinsteiger gewesen, Lahm, Neuer und wie sie alle heißen, die dann wirklich da auf ihrem Peak vielleicht waren. Aber spätestens da hat man wieder gesagt, okay, jetzt läuft's, wir ändern nichts mehr. So und die sind wirklich die anderen Länder. Gerade wenn man so in den unnationalen Mannschaften guckt, was Zolland macht, Portugal vor allem, Spanien sowieso, Frankreich, was die für Nationalmannschaften da umlaufen haben, die haben nicht aufgeholt, die haben überholt, muss man ganz klar sagen. Das wünschten wir uns eigentlich, dass man da einfach mal wieder ein bisschen die Scheuklappen öffnet und mal einfach Sachen hinterfragt, mal wieder diskutiert. Genau das mit diesen, wie man in den kleinen unteren Jugendmannschaften, ob man da was ändert mit dem Ballkontakt. Es geht ja in die richtige Richtung. Aber das fehlt dann definitiv, dass man da mal guckt, weil also einwohnerzahltechnisch von den Ressourcen, die wir haben, von den Jungs und Mädels, die kicken wollen, ist alles da. Man muss dann vielleicht einfach mal sich ein bisschen was abgucken, mal ein bisschen Ideen sammeln, weil die machen – also ich bin Fan von Portugal, muss man ganz klar sagen, wie die Fußball spielen in Lissabon und so, wenn man das sieht. Die müssen ja irgendwas anders machen dann. Und das mal dann mal… Da hast du jetzt echt ein Fass aufgemacht, Stefan, weil da fällt mir auch immer eine Sache ein. Das war die Außenverteidiger-Diskussion in Deutschland, als Philipp Lahm seine Karriere beendet hat. Und das haben wir ja auch mitbekommen. Da waren wir ja so 16 oder 17, Alter. Und das ist für mich das Paradebeispiel, was in Deutschland manchmal einfach falsch läuft. Da haben alle gesagt, ey, Scheiße, wir haben ja gar keinen Außenverteidiger mehr in diesem Land. Und dann war das wirklich so gefühlt, jeder, der gerade auslaufen konnte, sollte auf einmal Rechtsverteidiger spielen oder Linksverteidiger. Weil wir dann auf einmal gemerkt haben, so eine Kurzschlussreaktion, ey, die haben gerade keinen und wir brauchen jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz schnell wieder ein. Gleiches Thema mit der Stürmer-Diskussion gab es auch ganz lange. Haben alle gesagt, wir haben gar keinen richtigen Stürmer mehr. Keiner der groß ist, der mal ein Kopfballtor machen kann, Weihfess machen kann. Und plötzlich alle, die groß waren, auf einmal Stürmer. Und da habe ich mir gesagt, das könnt ihr nicht ernst meinen, weil ihr jetzt hier aus so einer Kurzschlussreaktion irgendeinen Spieler hervorbringen wollt, den es aber gerade nun mal nicht gibt, weil wir einfach vielleicht gerade drei haben, die richtig gute Sechser sind, aber nun mal kein Außenverteidiger und auch kein Stürmer. Das ist so, da wird immer so ein Schnellschuss, wird so ein Schnellschuss gehandelt, ohne da wirklich groß drüber nachzudenken. Und das funktioniert natürlich nicht. Das ist, Max hat gesagt, die Spanier, ich bin 10 von den Spaniern, die haben immer, die sind jetzt auch beim großen Turnier klar die Nationalmannschaft früh rausgeflogen, aber die haben immer in der Jugend gute, richtig gut ausgebildete Spieler. Da gehen richtig viele immer hoch, da werden viele Profis, weil die einfach ihr System haben, aber ihr System ja immer erneuern. Die verbessern sich ja.
Also wir sind schon sehr tief in einem, eigentlich dachte ich, sehr viel späteren Segment dieser Sendung, aber da will ich jetzt auch drin bleiben, denn das ist ja auch das, was dann immer, das ist quasi die populistische Spitze der Diskussion. Wo sind die Mittelstürmer? Warum sind die so schlecht ausgebildet? Hatte Mehmet Scholl recht, als er gesagt hat, jeder Nachwuchsleistungszentrum Spieler kann 4-3-3 und alle taktischen Systeme rückwärts furzen, aber kann nicht mehr ordentlich tribünn und so weiter. Das ist quasi die Speerspitze der Diskussion, die wir haben. Und wenn ich jetzt aber hier schon drei Experten sitzen habe, würde ich erstmal die Frage stellen, was machen denn andere Länder anders? Vielleicht, Stefan, kannst du mal vorlegen, weil wir jetzt schon öfter gesagt haben, man müsste mal Showklappen öffnen, andere Dinge angucken. Was sind denn da die Unterschiede zum Beispiel?
Also, nehmen wir mal Frankreich. So gefühlt jeder 17- 18-Jährige, der jetzt bei irgendeiner Mannschaft irgendwo in Europa spielt. Wenn ich danach gucke, habe ich bei der Hälfte sehe ich der Nationalität Frankreich. Oh, schon wieder ein Franzose. Komisch. Frankreich war ja auch das Vorbild für Deutschland mit Claire Fontaine. Also, die haben diese zentrale Ausbildungsstelle für die Nationalmannschaft geschaffen. Ich glaube, 1984 ging es los und so wirklich zur Heim-WM98 dann damals, haben die das sehr groß aufgezogen, das Ding. Und da werden die Spieler zum Beispiel aus ihren Klubs, ab der U14 war das, immer zusammengezogen, unter der Woche. Und da werden die in dieser zentralen Einrichtung in der Nähe von Paris, ist das, werden die dann unter der Woche ausgebildet zusammen. Die besten Spieler des Landes. Und am Wochenende gehen die wieder nach Hause in ihre Klubs und spielen da ganz normal in ihren Ligen. Ganz normales Turnierwochenende, Spielwochenende. Ausbildungskonzept natürlich schon etwas anders und gehobener, als es in Deutschland ist. Und dann kommt natürlich auch noch dazu, das darf man nicht vergessen, diese Spieler, die kommen jetzt mittlerweile oft genug aus sozialen Verhältnissen, die wir in Deutschland in der Regel so stark gar nicht kennen. Beim WM-Finale jetzt vor ein paar Monaten waren am Schluss, wenn mich jetzt nicht alles täuscht, bis auf den Torhüter waren nur noch dunkelhäutige Spieler bei den Franzosen auf dem Platz, also Spieler mit Migrationshintergrund und viele von denen kommen aus diesen sozialen Brennpunkten, wie man ja so schön sagt. Die haben eine andere Sozialisation als hier in Deutschland. Also diese, die haben diesen noch mehr diesen Drang, sich durchsetzen zu müssen. Genau, dann schaffen die das eher nicht über die Schule, sondern die müssen sich im Käfig behaupten und dann kommen die da weiter. Und das ist so eine Mischung in Frankreich. Und dann haben die natürlich auch wahnsinnig viel. Allein Paris hat, glaube ich, 12 Millionen Einwohner mit den ganzen Peripherie. Das ist einfach ein Schmelz-Tegel an wahnsinnig viel Fußballtalent, wie es in Europa so vergleichsweise eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt. England zum Beispiel hat immer nach Deutschland geguckt. Was machen die Deutschen? Wie machen die das? Warum können die uns 2010 4 zu 1 im Achtelfinale schlagen? Mit dem Thomas Müller, der zwei Tore macht mit irgendwelchen Jugendspielern, die keinen Mensch kennt. Damals. Und dann haben die aber angefangen. Die hatten ja immer dieses Premier League Problem. Also wahnsinnig viele Spieler. Nach Osmann haben wir eingekauft für die beste Liga der Welt. Absolut spektakulär, aber englische Spieler interessiert mich nicht. Wohl ich mir lieber noch einen Franzosen, einen Deutschen, einen Italiener und so weiter. Und dann haben die aber angefangen, die FA, die Vereine zu verpflichten, Abgaben zu machen. Für die FA, für die Ausbildung von Spielern und von Trainern. Das ist ganz wichtig in dem Zusammenhang. Aus meiner Sicht zumindest. Weil in England war es so, dass die Trainerscheine wahnsinnig viel Zeit beansprucht haben und wahnsinnig teuer waren. Und das haben die einfach nach unten gedrückt. Unter anderem durch die Gelder aus der Premier League. Also aus diesem riesen Milliardengeschäft haben die sich da ein bisschen Geld abgezogen und haben alle Strukturen überdacht und neu aufgestellt. Und wie von Geisterhand kommt, seit gefühlt fünf, sechs, sieben Jahren, gibt es auf einmal englische Spieler, die wirklich richtige Toptalente sind. Nicht nur gut genug für die zweite Liga, oder für die Premiership-Baddies, sondern wirklich für die Premier League. Ihr habt das vorhin schon gesagt, Jaden Central. Das sind alles Produkte aus diesem neuen englischen Weg. Die gab es früher einfach nicht. Die waren nicht da. Spanien ist aus meiner Sicht sehr speziell, weil die viele Sachen auch schon immer anders machen. Allein schon die Herangehensweise, wie die Trainer mit den Spielern arbeiten, was die für Strukturen da haben, dass die solche Enklaven immer noch haben, wie Athletic Bilbao oder Real Sociedad, wo es einfach eine andere Kultur herrscht in diesem ganzen Verein, die sich abkapseln, also die völlig gegen diese ganze Fußball-Globalisierung dem Ganzen entgegentreten sozusagen und sagen, ja hier, 100 Kilometer, einfach mal als Zahl genannt, ich weiß nicht, ob es 100 sind, vielleicht sind es auch nur 50 oder 150 Kilometer umkreist, das ist unser Bereich, da kommen unsere Spieler her, Ende der Geschichte. Es gibt verschiedenste Ansätze, und das hat der DFB ja auch versucht, aufzugreifen, die haben ihre Trainer nach England geschickt, nach Spanien geschickt, nach Portugal, nach Belgien, nach Holland, nach Kroatien, ganz wichtig, um zu gucken, wie funktionieren diese Ausbildungskonzepte in diesen Ländern und dann das Beste zusammenzutragen, zu bündeln und dann hier wieder neue Konzepte draus zu stricken. Das ist auch ein richtiger Ansatz aus meiner Sicht, aber da wiederhole ich mich jetzt, es dauert halt ehlendig lang, bis es dann umgesetzt wird. Das ist vielleicht auch eine Mentalitätsfrage, das ist nicht Föderalismus, Deutschland, Föderalismus, Frage mit diesen ganzen Landesverbänden, dass man da schwieriger auf einen Trichter kommt, aber es ist aus meiner Sicht auch echt eine Mentalitätsfrage, weil wir in Deutschland müssen immer irgendwas eine Idee haben, dann wird was beschlossen, dann wird ein Gesetz gemacht, dann wird es vielleicht irgendwann umgesetzt. Wenn der Niederländer irgendwas, da ist eine Straße, geht geradeaus und dann geht die nach links. Und der Niederländer läuft aber diagonal über diese Wiese drüber. Und wenn er dann sieht, dass das funktioniert, dann sagt er danach, lass uns doch eine Straße diagonal drüber machen, ist doch viel einfacher für alle. Wir laufen nicht geradeaus und nach links. Und dieses Denken fehlt bei uns. Und das macht es dann jetzt auch gerade für die Reformen mit dem DFB aus meiner Sicht wahnsinnig schwierig, das alles umzusetzen. Und diese guten Sachen, die man von draußen holt, wenn man jetzt schon ein bisschen abgehängt ist, und das ist definitiv der Fall, jetzt muss Deutschland halt wieder aufholen. Aber das dauert zu lang.
Und vielleicht war da auch der WM-Erfolg 2014 und das Narrativ, was darum gestickt wurde, kontraproduktiv. Denn wir alle wissen, wie es zu diesem WM-Titel kam. Also zum einen mit vier Innenverteidigern zum Beispiel in der Abwehrkette. Könnte man ja auch mal hinterfragen. Und es war halt einfach, es gehört sau viel Glück zu einem Turniererfolg. Gegen Algerien kannst du rausgehen, gegen Frankreich hast du im Grunde nur eine Chance nach Ecke. Und dann gibt es halt diesen Brasilien-Ausreißer, der aber auch von brasilianischer Seite her eigentlich relativ gut begründbar ist, warum die da so völlig überrollt wurden. Und dann Finale, was du eigentlich nicht gewinnen darfst. Also das war jetzt, ich habe es jetzt ein bisschen zu negativ gemacht, aber so kann man auf diese WM auch blicken. Und wir haben halt logischerweise, weil es gewonnen wurde und weil ja auch die Geschichten der Sieger schön sind, wurde es eben so gedreht, dass es eben nicht nur ein Erfolg jetzt im Jetzt ist, sondern ein Erfolg der Vergangenheit. Das ist eben das Ergebnis dieser Entwicklung war. Und da kann man sagen, komplett falsch ist das natürlich nicht, denn man muss sich nur EM 2000-Spiele angucken oder auch noch WM 2002 und so weiter umzusehen, was sich im technischen und taktischen verbessert hat im Fußball. Der deutsche Fußball in den 90ern war nicht zum Anschauen. Es war nicht innovativ. Die Spieler waren nicht gut geschult. Und Berti Vogts versucht irgendwie noch vor der WM 98, die Viererkette einzuführen, die WM 98, die Viererkette einzuführen, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98, die WM 98. Ich habe ein Zitat von einem Scout des FC Bayern, der gesagt hat – ich sage jetzt einfach mal nicht in welchem Jahr, aber solange ist es nicht her – der hat gesagt, ich kenne jeden Nationalspieler bis runter zu U15, da ist kein einziger Spieler mit dabei, der mal beim FC Bayern landen wird. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Also spricht die Expertinnen und Experten, die sehen das schon lange, und ihr habt das ja auch, dadurch, dass ihr involviert war, ja auch von innen gesehen. Was sind eure Gedanken dazu, wenn eben der Stefan uns hier ja sehr schön erklärt, was andere Nationen anders machen, und ihr ja auch quasi hier so ein bisschen in der Mission unterwegs seid. Wir müssen mal den Nachwuchsfußball neu überdenken.
Ja, also erstmal ist natürlich für uns aus der Perspektive des Spielers, haben wir natürlich jetzt aktiv erst seit ein, zwei, drei Jahren drauf geguckt, was ist da passiert. Als man selber, als wir selber teil dabei waren und uns mal mit den Besten da auch gemessen haben, finde ich, bekommt man das gar nicht mit so richtig. Sind wir jetzt gerade gut insgesamt oder sind wir eher schlecht oder auf was für einem Leistungsniveau befinden wir uns hier gerade? Das ist natürlich als Aktiver ganz, ganz schwierig überhaupt zu bewerten. Jetzt so im Nachhinein, muss ich sagen, und das hat Stefan ja wirklich sehr gut erklärt, was andere Länder gemacht haben oder was da für Innovationen bei denen gab, habe ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, was Stefan gerade schon mehrmals angesprochen hat, eine Umsetzung von einer Idee und es gibt ja sicherlich Ideen in diesem Land, ist ja nicht so, dass wir komplett planlos werden, aber dass eine Umsetzung immer so lange und so träge ist, dass wenn wir was beschlossen haben und das dann so machen, die anderen schon wieder drei gute Ideen hatten, aber die alle schon umgesetzt haben und dann schon wieder einen Schritt weiter weg sind und es wäre halt einfach mal, es gibt ja auch genug kompetente Leute in diesem Land fußballerisch, die sicherlich viel wissen und auch eine gute Idee haben, wie man das machen könnte. Man müsste es halt nur dann mal auf die Straße bringen und das relativ zügig und relativ schnell, damit wir da weiter dran bleiben, weil ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaube, es war Rudi Völler, der jetzt auch letztens noch mal gesagt hat, gerade haben wir noch mit Kai Havertz und so, haben wir noch ein paar Spieler, die wirklich gut sind, aber in fünf, sechs, sieben Jahren, wie du das auch schon angedeutet hast, Max, da haben wir ein richtiges Spielerproblem und dann wird es ganz problematisch und dann sind wir nicht nur ein Stück hinterher, sondern ganz weit hinterher. Um das dann wieder alles aufzuholen, das ist dann noch noch ein größerer Prozess und noch ein größerer Schritt. Deswegen müsste, wenn es jetzt Ideen gibt und die gibt es ja mit Sicherheit, das einfach mal gemacht werden. Das müsste einfach dann mal umgesetzt werden, weil sonst können wir uns ja hier alle in einem Kreis reden und sagen, ja es wäre ja schön, wenn wir das so hätten und guck mal, die Sparer machen es so und die Engländer machen es so und wir sagen alle, ja, ist es richtig oder passiert halt nichts. Und wenn man nichts ändert, kann man nicht erwarten, dass es besser wird. Wenn man immer das Gleiche macht, kann man nicht erwarten, dass es besser wird und Stillstand ist nun mal auch Rückschritt und das ist ja gerade so ein bisschen der Fall. Ich würde auch alles unterschreiben, was Stefan und Marius jetzt vor allem gesagt haben. Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen raus seit ein paar Jahren, aber da kann man so ein bisschen überspitzt sagen, genau das war es, was Stefan sagt. Tolle Ideen, genau das ist der Punkt, wie Leute, dass man schaut, was andere Länder machen. Viel mitbekomme man davon nicht, dass Deutschland rübergeguckt hat mal, also was die Trainer zum Beispiel angeht und so weiter, ja. Da ist einfach zum einen das Umsetzen. Ein Punkt, den ich noch anbringen möchte, ist zum Beispiel immer noch, dass man dann, ich glaube, es ist dieses einfache Denken und das bequeme Denken, dass man sagt, wenn man erfolgreich ist, dann ist man gleichzeitig auch gut, so nach dem Motto. Also das habe ich ja versucht, mit diesen Meisterschaften zum Beispiel zu sagen. Ja, also es ist toll, dass das professionell wird. Ich gönne jedem Jugendspieler dieses, hatten wir auch, Mannschaftsbus zu sitzen, Fans laufen hinterher und das Stadion füllt sich. Man spielt im Stadion vor 33.000, habe ich es ja geschafft, mit meinen Jungs am Meister zu werden. Das ist toll, dass das so auch diese Struktur mittlerweile hat, aber irgendwie hat das für unsere, vor allem auch für meine Sicht, so ein bisschen dieses Gewinnkost ist, was es wolle, so nach dem Motto. Und ich erinnere mich, ich habe mal ein kurzes Interviewausschnitt gesehen von von Lagelsmann. Das fand ich ganz interessant, der hat nämlich gesagt immer, warum muss man sagen, Ausbildung ist nicht gleich erfolgreich. Wenn ich Leute gut ausbilde, wenn ich jeden besser mache, wenn ich das Team besser mache, dann inkludiere ich das Erfolgreichsein eigentlich mit ein. Und bei uns ist so ein bisschen das Gefühl gewesen, ja, okay, wir haben jetzt nicht drei Spieler rausgebracht, wir haben jetzt nicht nur Profis genommen, wir sind Deutscher Meister geworden. Ja, also das ist so oft dieses Gefühl, ja, also mal ganz überspitzt wieder zu sagen, ich wäre lieber kein Deutscher Meister, wenn ich jetzt Profi wäre. Also wir sind jetzt auch Junioren, Deutsche Meister, aber schlichtweg davon kaufen, dass wir jetzt davon Profis gewonnen sind, ist jetzt nicht der Fall. Ja und dass man da vielleicht sagt, ja, diese Meisterschaften sind auch toll, auch wie sie zelebriert werden, aber sie müssten aus dem, von der Ausbildungseite kommen, dass wirklich toller Fußball gespielt wird, dass dann wirklich die Mannschaften, die dann wirklich die besten sind, wo ich da jedes Mal habe ich gesagt, okay, jetzt spielen gerade die zwei besten Mannschaften Deutschlands gegeneinander, aber DFB ist nicht bei der EM dabei. Also wo ich mir dann auch denke, so diese, es ist einfach zu sagen, ja, okay, jetzt haben wir einen deutschen Meister gefunden, das müssen die Top-Talente sein, das muss der beste Fußball sein, den Deutschland gerade spielt, das ist ein bisschen einfach gedacht finden, weil dann kann man einfach sagen, ja, schön, ihr habt die besten Deutschlands gefunden, aber im Vergleich zu den anderen laufen die immer noch gerade davon. Und das ist immer, dass man vielleicht sagt, ja, warum spielt man Fußball, ja, wer gewinnt, hat Recht, sagt man so oft. Das stimmt, ja, aber ich sage mal so, was wollte ich gerade sagen, in der Jugend auch, dass man diesen Sieges will, das wird ja oft, man kann schnell die Keune schwingen und sagen, ja, ihr habt so Wunschdenken und alle machen Luftbläschen und was weiß ich und alle klatschen sich in die Hände. Das ist ja nicht der Fall, den wir ansprechen wollen. Also es geht auch darum, zum Beispiel in unserem Fall, ich kenne einige Spieler, die dann bei Gladbach waren, zum Beispiel, die auch aussortiert worden sind, dann bei Oberhausen gespielt haben, die dann Profis geworden sind. Ja, das ist dann erfolgreich, wenn Leute den Sprung in den Profibereich schaffen und nicht, dass man sich auf die Fahne sagt, hier wir sind jetzt drei Mal im Finale gewesen. Ja, es kommt immer darauf an, da hat zum Beispiel, nehmen wir jetzt mal als Beispiel Gladbach, wenn die Sechster geworden sind und es geschafft haben, fünf Spieler rauszubringen, irgendwie Zweite Liga, Dritte Liga oder auch Erste in die eigene Mannschaft, die haben eine erfolgreiche Saison gespielt, als die Mannschaft die Deutsche Meister geworden ist, wenn sie weniger Spieler rausbringen. Das ist immer noch der Sinn einer Jugendabteilung, dass man Spieler rausbringt, dass man den Verein besser macht, dass man den DFB besser macht mit jungen Talenten. Genau wie Stefan gesagt hat, mit der Premier League. Wenn die sich wundern, da spielt kein Englander mehr. Mittlerweile kommen die alle hinterher, die jungen Spieler. Es kommen immer mehr Engländer auch in die Premier League, die da durchkommen. Bellingham zum Beispiel. Er wird definitiv Premier League-reif sein. Guck mal, bei der Invexer. Aber die haben mittlerweile die Spielerqualität da. Und das ist irgendwie ein bisschen paradox. Dieses Urgesetz, das man wirklich Ideen umsetzt, die auch da mal ein bisschen was ändern. Und gleichzeitig dieses, ja, dieses, wie ich gerade sagte, dieses Denken, Erfolg gibt Recht. Was ja stimmt, aber ein bisschen differenziert. Ein bisschen über den Tellerrand drüber gucken, wo dieser Erfolg herkommt. Also nur weil ich jetzt drei Spieler einkaufe, die zum Beispiel schon Bundesliga-reif sind, aus Frankreich, aus England. Klar wirst du dann Deutscher Meister. Ja, aber die werden dann halt Profis, aber der Rest halt nicht. Das ist dann, finde ich, finden wir ein bisschen zu einfach gedacht. Ja, auch einfach nicht erfolgreich gedacht. Wie Stefan gesagt hat, kann man ja auch eigentlich wirklich sagen, fangen wir alle zusammen ab der U17 an, kaufen uns die Leute zusammen, bringen die raus. Das ist nicht der Sinn einer Jugendarbeit.
Das sollte es auf jeden Fall nicht sein. Aber ich muss jetzt einfach aufgreifen, Max, du, eine Sache ist wirklich wichtig, glaube ich, auch wenn man dieses, so ein bisschen diese, man vernebelt sich selbst die Sicht auf die Dinge begreifen will. Dieser 2014er WM-Titel, der wird überall bis heute, das ist jetzt neun Jahre her, wird der verkauft als der große NLZ-Titel Deutschlands. Das ist die Generation, die aus dem NLZ kommt. Das ist unsere, das ist die Frucht unserer Ideen. Wenn man aber mal genau hinschaut, dann sind da bei der, beim, beim, bei der Final, beim Final Line-up, also bei der Aufstellung der deutschen Mannschaft im Finale, sind zwei Spieler dabei, die ich nach meiner Definition NLZ-Spieler nennen würde. Thomas Müller und Toni Kroos bei der Final-Aufstellung. Dann ist da der Klose dabei, den kann man rausrechnen. Der war damals schon, weiß nicht, 34 oder sowas. So, dann Neuer im Tor. Der hat seinen Bundesliga-Debüt, ich glaube 2006, spätestens 2007 gegeben. Schweini, Jahrgang 84, Lahm, Jahrgang 84. Das sind Spieler, die haben 2002, 2003 in der Bundesliga gespielt. Die haben dieses NLZ, diese normale NLZ-Ausbildung, haben die gar nicht genossen, da waren die schon zu alt. Und dann sind die ganzen 2009er Europa U21-Europameister dabei. Kedira war verletzt im Finale, der gehört aber eigentlich auch dazu. Hummels, Rüvedes, Boateng, Gürcérum Boateng, genau. Diese vier und die sind gerade so an der Schwelle. Sami Kedira hat schon 2005 beim VfB in der Bundesliga gespielt. Offiziellerweise geht dieses NLZ-Denken 2000-2001 los, so ungefähr. Die ersten zwei, drei Jahre waren aber faktisch ganz normale Ausbildungen, wie es schon die 10, 15, 20 Jahre davor war. Das hieß nur anders, das ist dann auf einmal NLZ. Aber die Inhalte waren immer noch dieselben. So richtig los ging es mit NLZ-Inhalten und Fußball erst ab 2004. Und da waren diese Spieler die 16, 17, also das sind keine klassischen NLZ-Spieler, das wird nur immer gerne so erzählt. Aber das gehört zu diesem Gesamtbild dazu. Ja, jetzt sind wir 2014 Weltmeister, das sind unsere Spieler, das ist unser NLZ-Jahrgang, das stimmt nur zur Hälfte, wenn überhaupt.
Ja, sehr guter und wichtiger Punkt. Und gleichzeitig ist ja auch das, was Marius und Alex gesagt haben, das ist ja so logisch, dass es kracht. Niemand würde widersprechen, dass die Erfolgsmessung schief läuft, dass der Erfolg nicht gemessen werden kann in Juniorenmeistertiteln, sondern dass der Erfolg wessen werden müsste in wie viele Spieler haben wir in den Profifußball bekommen. Vielleicht auch, ganz verrückter Gedanke, wie viele Spieler bei uns haben eine berufliche Ausbildung direkt im Anschluss an ihre gescheiterte Profifußballkarriere angefangen. Vielleicht sollte das ja auch nochmal mitgemessen werden, dass man eben den Plan A im Blick behält und nicht nur den fälschlichen Plan B verfolgt. Warum ist das so? Stefan, kannst du mir das erklären? Müssen wir da jetzt vielleicht über die Trainer sprechen? Das ist noch so ein Thema, über das haben wir uns so ein bisschen herumgewunden. Dabei spielen die ja eine ganz entscheidende Rolle zum Beispiel auch. Oder würdest du da jetzt erstmal woanders ansetzen, wenn es um diese Messung des Erfolgs geht?
Naja, also was ist die konkrete Frage jetzt?
Naja, es ist doch eigentlich völlig logisch, den Erfolg einer Jugendarbeit nicht daran zu messen, habe ich einen Titel gewonnen, sondern fünf Jahre später zu gucken auf das Werk eines Trainers und dann zu sagen, okay, wie viele deine Spieler sind im Profifußball gelandet, wie viele haben eine schulische Ausbildung abgeschlossen und so weiter. Warum wird das nicht gemacht?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Es wird ja teilweise gemacht. Es gibt ja immer mal wieder Statistiken, die dann europaweit erhoben werden, wie viele Nachwuchsspieler von Verein A, B und C spielen jetzt Profifußball. Da wäre zum Beispiel der VfB Stuttgart jedes Jahr Deutscher Meister, weil es gefühlt, ich weiß die genaue Zahl jetzt nicht mehr, aber die haben, glaube ich, über 50 Spieler in den ersten drei Ligen in Deutschland, die irgendwann mindestens, glaube ich, zwei Jahre ist, das ist der Parameter. Die müssen zwei Jahre zwischen der U15, U19 oder drei Jahre in diesem Verein gespielt haben. So und dann guckt man, okay, wer ist da jetzt vorne mit dabei und da gibt es in den unter den besten 30 Clubs Europas gibt es immer nur zwei oder drei deutsche Mannschaften, da ist der VfB dabei, mittlerweile vermutlich Schalke und dann noch sowas wie Hertha, ich habe es jetzt leider nicht mehr. Aber das ist, es gibt schon so ein paar, also so eine Kennzeichnungspflicht, wenn man das so nennen mag, aber du sprichst halt einen wichtigen Punkt an, die Dropout-Quote allein aus dem NLZ raus, ist ja schon so exorbitant hoch, so Systemimmanent, dass man einfach zwingend schauen muss, dass man diese Spieler nicht nur als Spieler ausbildet, sondern auch als Menschen und Persönlichkeiten. Und das fällt halt immer wieder, erfahrungsgemäß fällt das immer wieder unter den Tisch. Und da gibt es verschiedenste Faktoren dafür. Aus meiner Sicht der größte oder einer der größten ist definitiv der Trainer. Weil je älter die Spieler sind, je höher die Jahrgänge sind ab der U15, wenn es in diese Leistungsklassen geht, dann ist es auch so, dass die Trainer eine entsprechende Motivation, zusätzliche Motivation noch haben. Die gucken dann, können die vielleicht von der U16 in die U17 aufsteigen, können die von der U17 in die U19 aufsteigen. Ach, guck mal den Kohfeldt an in Bremen, der war mal U19-Trainer, dann war er U23-Trainer, zack, Bundesliga, das kann ich doch auch. Und dann wird es schwierig, weil da treffen so viele Interessenfelder aufeinander, dass die dann einfach, nicht einfach, aber dass die am Schluss im Zweifel, vielleicht sind die festangestellt und haben eine Familie zu Hause, die sie ernähren müssen und müssen dann schauen, dass sie in diesem Job bleiben. Und wenn dann ihr Vorgesetzter sagt, ja so und so musst du das jetzt machen, dann sagen die natürlich im Zweifel eher, ja genau, so machen wir das jetzt. So wie du das sagst, so machen wir das. Ihr hättet aber vielleicht für sich selber eine ganz andere Idee, das zu machen. Es wird quasi den Leuten nach dem Mund geredet und dann, dann fangen die Probleme an bzw. dann ist man schon mitten drin und dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Also es sind zu viele, da zern zu viele Leute an zu vielen Interessen, die sie entweder selber verfolgen oder die, die, die in aufoktoriiert werden, dass das am Schluss, und das ist der zentrale Punkt, es muss immer um den Spieler gehen. Es muss immer um den Spieler gehen und das wird, je höher die oder je älter die Spieler werden, je höhere Spielklassen sind, wird es immer weniger aus meiner Sicht, weil es dann, weil da zu viel dran hängt und dann kommt Berater und dann kommt die Eltern und dann kommen Freunde und dann kommt, gibt es Probleme in der Schule und so weiter. Und deswegen sollte man, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, wirklich gucken, was ist jetzt wirklich mein Plan A und was ist vielleicht noch mein Plan B.
Das was du gerade gesagt hast, Stefan, das ist eigentlich ja leider die klassische Definition für die perfekte eines Zielkonfliktes, was da in der Jugend passiert. Ein Trainer, der auch aufsteigen will, der aber eigentlich als Aufgabe hat, die Spieler seine Jungs zu verbessern. So und wenn ich natürlich an einem Seil ziehe und ziehe die beiden in die falsche Richtung, dann ist das ganz schwierig und das ist leider ist das ein perfekter Zielkonflikt, der da eigentlich herrscht. Weil der Aufgabe des Jugendtrainers, und das ist ja, müsste man ja auch mal sagen, ist ein sehr schwieriger Job, ein guter Jugendtrainer zu sein. Das ist extrem schwierig. Du musst menschlich top sein, du musst mit den Jungs umgehen können, du sollst den Fach, du sollst dem Wissen vermitteln. Das ist eine außergewöhnliche Basics, du solltest aber trotzdem deren Freiraum lassen, das ist ja extrem schwierig, das gut umzusetzen. Aber das ist nun mal leider echt ein Problem, dass da viele Trainer auch ambitioniert sind, wie du es gesagt hast, mit dem Gedanken, ach guck mal, für mich selber könnte ich ja mit einer Meisterschaft auch mal ins Rampenlicht gerückt werden oder mit sonstigen Erfolgen, um dann auch auf die nächste Stufe zu kommen. Und dann sind die Spieler und die Ausbildung der Spieler leider nicht mehr Priorität Nummer eins, was sie aber nun mal sein sollten.
Und warum, glaubt ihr, gibt es so viele Trainer, die gerade in den U19-Mannschaften, U23-Mannschaften, wenn es sie noch gibt, eben letztlich immer das Ziel Profi-Fußball haben? Ist das öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit? Geht es da vielleicht auch um Geld? Denn man kann ja auch als Jugendtrainer sich einen Ruf verarbeiten. Es dauert halt nur sehr viel länger, weil ja logischerweise erst über die Jahre hinweg dann sichtbar wird. Ach guck mal, immer dieser Trainer, also Norbert Elgert ist da ja ein super Beispiel, natürlich auch das Beispiel in Deutschland, aber da gibt es ja auch noch andere. Und wir hatten hier zum Beispiel Nico Willig schon häufiger vom VfB Stuttgart, der auch, also sowohl Elgert als auch Willig haben beide bewusst die Entscheidung getroffen, im Jugendbereich zu bleiben. Willig war mal Interimstrainer, lief auch nicht so gut, also er wäre jetzt nicht Cheftrainer geworden. Er hat aber auch sehr glaubhaft von Anfang an schon gesagt, möchte ich gar nicht, ich möchte weiter bei der U19 bleiben, ich möchte einzelne Spieler in den Profifußball bekommen. Also liegt es dann vielleicht auch daran, dass die zu schlecht bezahlt werden und dass die eben sehen, sie stehen ja quasi genauso wie die Spieler an der Schwelle zu richtig viel Geld. Also von Juniorenbereich bis hin zu Profifußball, da ist der große Unterschied. Da sind quasi die großen Töpfe und die viel, viel kleineren Töpfe. Was denkt ihr, Marius und Alex?
Auf jeden Fall ist das der Punkt. Also Stefan, du hast das super gesagt, dieser Interessenkonfig. Genau da ist er nämlich. Und lustigerweise war der erste Gedanke immer bei mir, den ich mir jetzt, wo ich quasi abgeschlossen habe, mal so ein bisschen von außen auf dieses Konstrukt aufgucke, habe ich mir immer die Frage gestellt. Eigentlich muss den Verein bewusst sein, dass der U17-Posten und der U19-Posten der wichtigste Posten ist. Also normalerweise muss da, da muss alles hieb- und stichfest passen eigentlich. Und es ist ja vollkommen okay und das ist auch menschlich, dass wir ganz viel erlebt haben, auch Jugendtrainer, die ihre eigene Karriere haben wollen. Ja, also die, die das, wenn man es mal so sagen will, Sprungbrett sehen. Ja, genau das, wenn ich hier Erfolgefeier an U19, irgendwann kommt der, mache ich meine Karriere auch als Trainer. So ein Wunschdenken, glaube ich, wäre ein Trainer, der sich quasi nichts mehr beweisen muss. Ja, also der, der wirklich das Ziel hat, er, oder er profiliert sich darüber, wie seine Spieler den Anschluss an die, an die, an die Profi-Abteilung schaffen. Und was so am nächsten drankommt, das ist aber meine persönliche Meinung zum Beispiel, wo ich gesehen habe, dass so von auch auf Plätzen, wo ich gegen die gespielt habe, wo das am nächsten rankommt, waren das vor allem bei Real Madrid, ehemalige Profis beispielsweise, das übernommen hatten, die dann den Trainerweg eingegangen sind, wo man auch sagt, die haben sich dann auf die, auf die Trainerbank gesessen, ich bin immer Fan von Trainern, die ein bisschen beobachten, die dann wirklich konstruktive Inputs im Spiel geben und nicht einfach nur brüllen und am besten den Joystick hinten am Platz haben und alle Spieler lenken wollen. Und solche Leute, die müssen eigentlich niemandem was beweisen, die kommen dann auch nicht, die hatten die große Karriere, vielleicht wollen dann ein paar natürlich ihre eigene Karriere pushen, aber das wäre eigentlich das beste Denken, wo man sagt, da ist keiner dabei, der seine eigene Karriere, der auch vielleicht nicht, dass klar spielt Geld noch, da muss man einfach ehrlich sein, da muss man nicht alles schönreden, die vielleicht auch Geld im Blick haben, die natürlich dann einen Vertrag wittern und was natürlich, da kommen so viele Sachen rein, was wir auch hatten mit, oft kommt der Spruch, ja der muss guter Trainer sein, aber auch ein super Sozialpädagoge. Haben wir jetzt persönlich, das ist ja auch im Buch, vielleicht nicht ganz so gut mitbekommen, wir haben auch andere Fälle mitbekommen, wo das nicht so ganz ist, wo man sagt, das ist pädagogisch super, aber so einen braucht man da eigentlich. Und jetzt habe ich viel erzählt und man merkt, da sind viele Punkte, die ein sehr guter 19-Trainer erfüllen muss oder ein Jugendtrainer, sowohl sich selber ein bisschen zurückstellen, dass es um den Spieler geht, dass es darum geht, sie rauszubringen und sich nicht vielleicht um sich selber rauszubringen, dass man auch Zwischenmenschliches gut handelt, neben dem Platz, wie Stefan der Toll gesagt hat, es geht um den Spieler. Es gibt auch mal Probleme neben dem Platz, die man handeln muss, dass man die auf Position hält, es ist immer noch Pubertät, es ist immer noch Jugend, dass man die quasi dann nicht nur als Maschinen sieht, dass man sie taktisch weiterführt. In Deutschland wundert man sich, wo sind die Deutschen mit ihren Charakterzügen, wo ist so ein Schweinsteiger, wo sind Leute, die ihr Mund auf dem Platz aufmachen. Das gehört dazu, dass man den Spieler auch sich entwickeln lässt, dass man ihn sein lässt, so wie er ist, auch mal dreimal gegen die Wand laufen lässt, ihm dann mal vielleicht ein paar Tipps gibt und nicht sich da irgendwie profilieren muss. Also wir haben da so viele Geschichten noch außerhalb, wo man mal auch in Dresden habe ich das erlebt, wo Trainer sich so ein bisschen selber profilieren wollen, die so ihre eigenen Stars sein wollen. Man sieht ja auch Julian Nagelsmann zum Beispiel, so als tollen Trainer, wo vielleicht manche Trainer sagen, das könnte ich auch sein, ja in so einem jungen Alter, sehr moderner Trainer, ich könnte auch so einen Weg gehen vielleicht. Ja, es sind ja auch viele talentierte junge Trainer unterwegs, aber ich glaube, das ist schwierig als Trainer. Man muss, es ist schwerer als Trainer, glaube ich, mal den Mund zu halten und einen Schritt zurückzugehen und ein bisschen die Züge locker zu lassen, als wie man es halt kennt, alles kontrollieren zu wollen. Man hat einen Spielplan, man hat einen Plan im Training, aber mal so ein bisschen zurücktreten und die Spieler mal wirklich, ja sich entwickeln lassen und eigentlich so wie es jetzt auch, die Stimmen ja ein bisschen lauter werden, so als Beobachter da sind. Ja, also den Mut haben, die Spieler mal machen zu lassen, die richtigen Inputs zu geben, an den richtigen Stellen, wenn sie merken, die kommen vom Weg ein bisschen gerade ab, vom Ziel, den man im Auge hat. Und das ist wesentlich schwerer, sich hinzusetzen, ich bin der Trainer, ihr hört mir zu, ich habe meinen Plan und mach ihr meine Karriere ein bisschen. Also ich habe auch, ich glaube du auch, ich kann einige Trainer, gibt es schon überall auf jedem Weg, wo ich sage, die hätten uns sofort stehen und liegen lassen, wenn sie wüssten, die könnten jetzt bei Stuttgart, was weiß ich, oder bei irgendeinem Profi-Fall oder der nächste 19 Trainer werden, die hätten uns stehen und liegen lassen. Das war auch gefühlsmäßig manchmal klar, dass wenn ein Angebot reinfliegt, dass er sofort weg wäre. Die sind leider dann nun mal Teil des ganzen Systems. Das System Profi fängt auch für die Trainer, einige mittlerweile in der U17, in der U19 an. Vor allem weil wir bei Dortmund waren, wir haben das ja wirklich mitbekommen. Die waren alle fest angestellt und die werden auch da ein schlechtes Geld verdient haben. Aber die ganzen Summen, die ja dann schon für die Spiele ausgegeben wurden, da muss man ja alles sehen. Dortmund, für Jugendspieler geben die schon relativ viel Geld aus. Und die wissen, weil deren Plan ist, ich möchte die hochbringen. Das heißt, der Trainer kriegt Druck und dem wird gesagt, ey, wir stellen die hier so gute Spieler hin. Sieh zu, dass du mit denen Meister wirst, damit die hochkommen. Und dann sind die auch Teil des Systems. Und sich da als Trainer so stark zu sein, sich dagegen zu stellen und zu sagen, ja, ich möchte aber auch hier gucken, dass ich Jungs gut ausbilde. Das ist schon extrem schwierig oder vielleicht auch manchmal dann unmöglich. Weil das System nun mal gerade so ist, wie es ist. Und dadurch, dass dann die Trainer da auch gar nicht so viel Entscheidungsgewalt haben, vielleicht, sondern einfach nur darauf getrimmt werden, du musst jetzt hier gewinnen, sonst ist das alles schlecht. Und dann hat er, wie Stefan auch gesagt hat, vielleicht auch Angst um seinen Job. Ich glaube, ein fest angestellter Jugendtrainer bei Dortmund in der U17 oder 19, der möchte ungern seinen Job verlieren. Der wird einen neuen wiederfinden. Aber ich glaube, die wissen auch ganz genau, was das erst mal für eine gute Position ist in Deutschland. Da können wir jetzt mal die großen Vereine in Deutschland aufmachen, die wahrscheinlich finanziell und von der Stahlkraft in Deutschland so das Niveau von Borussia Dortmund haben. Da würde ich Bayern München und RB Leipzig vielleicht noch nennen. Und dann fallen die meisten, glaube ich, aber schon ab. Den Job finanziell, vor allem auch finanziell, genau. Und den Job möchte man, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt verlieren. Wir haben es ja ab und zu erlebt, wo man mal quasi nicht auf Meisterschaftskurs war, wo man vielleicht mal nach zwei, drei Spielen unentschieden mal auf Platz vier oder Platz fünf gerutscht ist. Also dann hat der Busch aber gebrannt bei uns in Dortmund. Ja, dann waren das auch sehr, wie man es sich aus dem Profibereich wahrscheinlich kennt, wir haben es ja nicht kennengelernt, aber dann ging es wirklich darum, um jeden Preis wieder auf Kurs zu kommen, zu gewinnen. Ja, wo man ja auch mal sagt, Teil des Systems sind, muss man sich erstmal gegenstellen und sagen, Leute, wir sind zwar Fünfter geworden, haben aber so und so viele Spieler rausgemacht. Die Jungs wurden besser, das wäre nicht so gut, dann glaube ich, dass sie da rausgekommen sind. Nur um zu zeigen, was da für ein Druck auf dem Kessel ist. Wir hatten das Alex in seinem letzten und 19. Jahr, ich in meinem ersten, in dem Jahr, wo wir zusammen gespielt haben, hatten wir generell eine ganz schlechte Saison für Dortmunder verhältnisse von der Platzierung und dann hatten wir auch wieder, glaube ich, zwei Spiele unentschieden und dann noch eins verloren, also drei Spiele oder so, die unigepunktet wurden. Da haben wir samstags gespielt, da war aber am nächsten Sonntagmorgen um 8 Uhr Videoanalyse, alle Mann und die ging bis 15 Uhr nachmittags. Da haben wir wirklich 90 Minuten Fußball bei uns reingezogen nochmal, unser ganzes Spiel, alles. Jede Sekunde. Jede Sekunde, da wurde uns vorgerechnet, wie viele Punkte wir jetzt noch holen müssen, damit wir da, damit wir noch zur deutschen Meisterschaft da reinziehen können. Dann sind wir danach noch auf den Platz gegangen und haben noch Sachen gemacht. Also da haben wir wirklich von 8 Uhr morgens bis nachmittags 15, 16 Uhr uns das Spiel von Samstag angeguckt, was wir da verloren haben. Und da sieht man ja auch, was da für ein Druck dann ist. Ein Druck auf dem Kessel. Das waren schon die Dimensionen, wo wir uns da bewegt haben. Für alle Beteiligten. Jetzt muss er auch mal sagen, genau das, was man ist, auch auf den Trainer. Jetzt im Nachhinein selbstverständlich. Also der, der da gewinnen möchte, gewinnen muss, je nachdem, wie man sagen will.
Ja, kann ich mir nur zu gut, zu gut vorstellen, wie das dann da abgeht. Ich habe nur eine Kleinigkeit, auch wenn das jetzt eine Herspalterei ist, aber ihr und ich, ihr sprecht immer vom Trainer. Und vielleicht geht es damit schon los, auch wenn es echt nur eine Marginalie ist, aber vielleicht muss man sagen, es gibt Bundesligatrainer, das sind Trainer mit erwachsenen Menschen, die in der Regel erwachsenen Menschen, die Profifußball machen, da geht es um wahnsinnig viel Geld. Und vielleicht müsste man diese Angestellten bei diesen U-Mannschaften, egal ob im NLZ oder woanders, nicht Trainer nennen, sondern Coach nennen. Also nur eine Kleinigkeit. Aber aus meiner Sicht ist das, da gibt es noch einen Unterschied dazwischen. Weil es zählen in Ausbildungs-Jugendbereich, zählen noch andere Faktoren als nachher im Profibereich. Und es wird aber immer von oben nach unten gedacht. Es wird immer vom Profi auf die Ausbildung gedacht. Dieses klassische Trickle-Down ist da so krass wie sonst nirgendwo ausgeprägt. Und da könnte man vielleicht so ein bisschen versuchen, das ein etwas abzuschwächen.
Das Wort schließe mich an, Stefan. Das ist vielleicht Harschballerei, aber der Sinn dahinter überhaupt nicht. Also wirklich gar nicht. Wir haben das gemerkt, wir sind jetzt 23 bis 24, wir haben das teilweise schon währenddessen als Jugendspieler gemerkt, wo man sagt, klar, bei den Profis wird das so gemacht, also muss das bei der Jugendmannschaft genauso laufen. Ja und dann teilweise jetzt im Nachhinein auch, wenn ich es ehrlich sage, ein bisschen albern, was teilweise für Maßnahmen von Trainer ergriffen worden sind, gegen als Mitte 30- 40- 50-Jährige, gegen 16-Jährige, irgendwelche, ja okay, dann gehen wir jetzt mal laufen und bis ihr kotzt, bis hin zum Licht aus gegen gegen irgendeinen Tabellenletzten und Motivationssprachen und Flaschen werden geschmissen und lauft, lauft, lauft. Dann weiß ich, wo man denkt, ja klar, bei den Profis, da geht es um viel Geld, da geht es um Gewinn, da wird es, da wirst du daran gemessen, dass du sie geholtest. So musst du jetzt vielleicht nicht als gestandener Erwachsener mit dem 15-Jährigen, 16-Jährigen, 17-Jährigen umgehen und genau wie du sagst, dieses gleiche, diesen gleichen Maßstab in der Jugend ansetzt. Ja, und dann teilweise irgendwelche, welche Maßnahmen ergreifen, wo man sagt, hey, also die sind vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen übertrieben. Also die Härte soll ja da sein, ist ja auch ein wieder ein schmaler Gerät. Die Professionellität und so soll ja da sein und das ist ja dann auch der, der Sprung sollte ja nicht so groß sein, so den Profis. Aber man darf nicht vergessen, genau das, was Stefan sagt, ist kein Bundesliga-Trainer. Er hat da keine gestandenen Profis, die da ihre Millionen verdienen und das als wirklich als Beruf ausüben, wo man auch mal sagen kann, du nächste Woche spielst nicht mehr in Berlin, da spielst du in Stuttgart oder so. Guck, wie du rüberkommst. Dafür wird dir auch gut entlohnt. Das ist dafür sein Job. Letztendlich sind wir immer noch Jugendspieler, die quasi Schüler sind. Ja, da musst du nicht den gleichen Maßstab hinter setzen und so draufhören. Also oft genau das, was das ist jetzt auch abschließend, was Stefan sagt, man oft bei Relegen gesehen, dass die Trainer in der Jugend oft so versuchen, das Gleiche zu machen wie Trainer in der Bundesliga und dann irgendwelche Motivationssachen, wo man dröht, irgendwie Drakonische, warum man Pass falsch spielt, wo man sagt, ey, 16 Jahre, der da, wo man Fehlpass spielt, der da, wo man schlechte Spiele haben oder so oder da ist zu Hause mal irgendein Auslegen. Schiefeltern haben sich gestritten, weiß ich. Ja, dass man da mal ein bisschen einfach differenzierter sieht und sich, genau wie deswegen sage ich, Haarspalterei ist das Wort, ob sie jetzt Coach nennen oder was weiß ich, aber der Sinn ist, ist definitiv keine Haarspalterei, dass man da kein Bundesliga-Trainer ist. Man ist da kein Trainer. Man sollte vielleicht, wenn es auch ein bisschen blöder klingt, man ist eher Sozialpädagoge als Trainer. Genau, weil Marius hat das ja auch angesprochen, diese fußballerische Ausbildung ist möglich. Ja, also ich kann mich jetzt hinsetzen und ein halbes Jahr die Taktik lernen und die Trainingsform lernen. Dann kann man besser werden als taktischer Trainer, das kann man lernen, finde ich. Also sich angucken, wie sind Formationen, wie kann man gute, effektive Trainingsmethoden schaffen. Das ist das eine. Aber die Qualität zu haben, sich hinzustellen und ein guter Mensch, ein guter Pädagoge, gute soziale Beziehungen aufzubauen zu spielen, das kann man nicht lernen, aber das ist viel wichtiger. Der beste Spruch, den ich immer, um das in Worte zu fassen, ist, ein Spieler hat einen Trainer, aber ein Trainer hat 23 Spieler. Also du musst dieses Ungleichgewicht lösen können als Trainer, dass du, oder als Coach wieder sagen, du musst dir bewusst sein, dass du zu allen richtig die anpacken musst. Ja, und das ist schwer, wie wir gerade eben gesagt haben, aber das ist nötig. Wir haben wirklich tolle Beispiele auch als Trainer, wo die Autorität klar war, wer hier der Chef ist als Coach, der mit dir sprechen konnte, wo die Kommunikation gestimmt hat, wo das teilweise auf Orgenhöhe war, wo man sich auch getraut hat, was zu sagen, wo die Entwicklungen vordergrund standen, wo ich da auch sein sollte als Pädagoge beispielsweise, die auch menschlich zu fördern, als Typen zu fördern, die auch Entscheidungen treffen können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir es auch ganz oft gemerkt, quasi dieses Korsett und einmal alles absägen, was nicht da reinpasst, wenn der Mund aufgemacht wird, wenn keine Kommunikation stattfindet, wenn es eher darum geht, durch brüllende Autorität auszustrahlen, immer beweisen zu müssen, wer gerade Chef ist. Und das ist der klackende Punkt, dass man da sagt, ja eigentlich ist es mehr Pädagogik. Und das kann man halt schwer lernen, dass man sagen muss, ok, Marius ist eher so ein Typ, den würde ich jetzt vor dem Spiel nicht motivierend anbrüllen, das kriegt er selber hin. Aber es gibt auch Spielertypen, die haben wir auch kennengelernt, die musst du nur ein bisschen bei der Ehre packen, die wären für dich 90 Minuten hoch und runter gelaufen. Aber du musst sie halt anders anpacken können, du musst Spiele anders, das ist die große Qualität, die man braucht.
Ja, also Fußballpädagogen sollten wir es vielleicht nennen statt Trainer, da schreibt ihr auch in eurem Buch, die Jahrtausendfußballer Marius und Alex werden von 80er und 90er Trainern trainiert, die erstens ganz anders sozialisiert wurden auf dem Fußballplatz, zweitens eine äußerst leistungsbezogene Ausbildung erlebten und drittens nicht automatisch gute Pädagogen und Menschenversteher sind. Abschlusstabelle schlägt Empathie, Meisterschaft schlägt Persönlichkeitsentwicklung. Und das scheint mir nämlich der Nukleus zu sein, neben allen Reformen, Strukturen, Transferstrategien und so weiter. Die Empathie gegenüber den Menschen – ich habe wirklich schon viele Fußballerbiografien gelesen oder Sportlerbiografien, ein paar davon stehen hier hinter mir im Bücherregal – und es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie eine Konstante sich durch alles durchzieht für den Sportler oder die Sportlerin. Gibt es eine wichtige Person und das ist der Trainer oder die Trainerin. Und wenn es da nicht funktioniert, dann kann das Karrieren beenden. Wenn es da funktioniert, dann kann das Karrieren fördern und von jetzt auf gleich kann sich alles verändern. Das kann man auch in eurem Buch wunderbar nachlesen. Die kurze Zeit mit Hannes Wolf – sie wird zumindest im Buch ganz positiv beschrieben – dann wurde er wegbefördert, weil er war zu erfolgreich. Und dann kam mir Benjamin Hofmann, ein Trainer, da kommt viel vor in diesem Buch, aber nicht viel in positiven Sinne. Und der Unterschied zwischen beiden – das Taktische, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, das wird auch gar nicht so erwähnt, aber das Empathische ist der Unterschied. Und das bringt nämlich mich zu einem weiteren Punkt, weil das auch – also ich will euch jetzt gar nicht zwingen, dass ihr da jetzt noch mal irgendwie öffentlich Dinge zu sagt, das kann man wirklich sehr gut hier nachlesen und auch in vielen anderen Sportlabiografien – dass Trainer gute Pädagogen sein sollten im Jugendbereich ist eigentlich eine Binse, aber es muss noch mal festgestellt werden. Ich finde, es kommt hier aber noch ein zweiter Aspekt hinzu und da komme ich noch mal auf etwas zurück, was ich vor einer Stunde oder so gesagt habe, der Druck, der im System ist. Denn wir sprechen hier ja auch – also wir sprechen nicht nur über viele Spieler oder junge Menschen, die ihre berufliche Ausbildung hinten anstellen und so weiter, sondern wir sprechen ja auch über Leistungssport. Und was bedeutet Leistungssport? Leistungssport bedeutet Raubbau am eigenen Körper, dem man auch bewusst eingeht. Und ich meine, ihr seid da gute Beispiele für. Ich habe mir versucht, alle Verletzungen zu notieren, die im Buch vorkommen, und ich bin mir sicher, dass ich was vergessen habe. Allein dreimal der Oberschenkel war es bei dir, Malius. Bei Alex habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, was hatten wir alles? Faszienriss am Hüftbeuger, die Rückenmuskeln waren komplett verkrampft, durftest aber wieder zu früh trainieren, hast dann gleich einen Rückschlag danach errichten. Und es gab noch so Dinge wie mit eigentlich dicken Knöcheln zu Ende gespielt und so weiter, weil man will ja auch als Spieler selbst, also da müsste man ja auch geschützt werden von den Pädagogen um einen außen rum. Gleichzeitig wollen die Pädagogen aber ja auch, dass man spielt. Und das würde mich jetzt nämlich noch als einzelner Aspekt interessieren, wenn ihr jetzt zurückblickt auf eure Zeit im Leistungssport, wo ihr eben bis ganz nah an den Profibereich gekommen seid, aber es eben nicht reingeschafft habt. Und wenn ihr euch jetzt anguckt, einfach in welchem körperlichen Zustand ihr seid und durch welche Verletzungen ihr hindurchgespielt habt, wie denkt ihr jetzt über den gesundheitlichen Aspekt der Mühle, die ihr dadurch laufen habt?
Also vorne weg, wenn man natürlich viel Sport treibt und einen Sport betreibt, den es Zweikämpfe gibt und so, der Intensiv ist dann, gehören Verletzungen natürlich dazu. Das Problem ist nur oder was wir ganz oft erlebt haben, war zum Beispiel jetzt so auf so was anzuspielen wie mit Schmerztabletten. Das wird ja auch von Profis oft mal genannt, unter Schmerztabletten spielen mit Tape und so. Da wird ja immer oder wurde ja ganz oft sage ich mal in dieser Männerfußballwelt noch, wenn ich das jetzt mal so in Anführung sprechen sagen darf, bist du eine Pussy oder nicht? Kannst du spielen, nur weil du mal, weil du jetzt umgeknickt bist oder nicht? Und dann ist halt immer die Frage, wie geht ein Trainer wirklich damit um? Wie, wie ernst nimmt der dich? Für wie voll nimmt der dich, dass du deinen eigenen Körper kennst, dass du jetzt vielleicht spielen kannst mal, weil es wirklich nur eine Prellung ist und da kann nix passieren oder du hast wirklich eine Verletzung, wo man einfach mal sagen muss, ja, wenn du könntest du jetzt zwei Schmerz-Habletten reinhauen, tapen und dann spielen, das würde schon irgendwie gehen, nur förderlich ist es nicht. Und das ist auch in der Jugend und das ist wirklich so ganz oft auch ein Problem, dass da immer schon so drauf abgestellt wird, ja du willst auch Profi werden. Dann musst du auch halt mal da durch. Und ich meine, wir sind jetzt, wir haben viele Verletzungen. Ich für mich kann sagen, ich hätte auch ganz, ganz zwei, drei weniger gehabt. Aber es beeinträchtigt mich jetzt in meinem Leben zum Glück nicht total. Ich habe so ein paar Sachen, vor allem mit meinen Leisten, so habe ich so, wenn ich zum Beispiel nachts schlafe und mich immer umdrehe, das ist nicht so ganz optimal immer. Aber es ist jetzt nichts mega dramatisches dabei.
Ja, aber sorry, du bist 23. Ich möchte von einem 23-Jährigen nicht hören, dass er sich nachts nicht umdreht gerne, weil er Leistenprobleme hat.
Ja, das ist jetzt, ja, das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich für manche ziemlich hart an. Wie gesagt, das hat bei mir auch angefangen schon mit 12, 13 und hat sich das so immer ein bisschen durchgezogen. Man lernt damit umzugehen. Es wäre schöner, hätten wir keine Verletzungen gehabt. Es ist auch manchmal einfach ein bisschen zu viel für den Körper, auch für den Körper, der noch wächst, der sich noch weiterentwickelt in den jungen Jahren, der ja eh unter Stress steht, sowohl mental, erstmal vom Kopf her mit dem Druck und dann wirklich auch körperlich. Es ist viel, es ist manchmal definitiv auch zu viel. Und wie ich gerade gesagt habe, ist es nun mal das Problem, wie gehen die Verantwortlichen mit den Spielern um, für wie voll nehmen sie sie, wenn ein Spieler sagt, ich bin jetzt mal wirklich verletzt oder ich bin auch einfach mal wirklich nur körperlich am Ende. Das muss ja nicht immer direkt sich in einer Verletzung sich ausdrücken. Es kann ja auch einfach mal sein, dass wenn man jetzt die ganzen letzten Monate hin und her gependelt ist, gefahren ist, gespielt, dass man einfach mal sagt, ich bin, ich bin platt, kann ich mehr. Das muss ich ja nicht direkt immer im extremen Fall einer Verletzung äußern. Für wie voll wird man dann genommen? Und wie, auf welcher Ebene begegnet man sich da? Und das ist definitiv verbesserungswürdig. Wer hat keine Frage. Da würde ich auch direkt, ich musste gerade schmunzeln, weil er sagt, das beheinträchtigt mich nicht viel im Leben. Marius muss auch schmunzeln. Ich habe jetzt, 1.1. habe ich einen Bandscheibenvorfall bekommen und lag auch zwei Monate extrem flach.
Hast du nicht auch ganz früh im Januar Geburtstag?
Nein, 27. habe ich Geburtstag. Ach so, du warst das, Entschuldigung. Klar, den kann man so kriegen. Ich bin aber ziemlich der Meinung, ich habe eh immer ganz, ganz Probleme im unteren Rücken. Genau da, wo er jetzt sitzt, habe ich, glaube ich, mein kleines Päckchen all zu tragen. Und da muss man einfach ehrlich sein. Und da stehen wir beide auf zu. Und das kommt, glaube ich, in dem Buch dann am Ende ganz gut rüber, warum wir sagen, um jeden Preis vierte Liga, dritte Liga wollen wir nicht. Wir merken jetzt schon, dass der Körper gelitten hat. Dafür sind wir auch gerne bereit. Wir würden es auch immer wieder so machen, weil wir haben Sachen erlebt, die muss man erst mal erleben, die wir erleben durften. Das soll dann aber auch entlohnt werden. Also es klingt dann ganz blöd. Vielleicht klingt das für manche, die können das nicht ganz verstehen. Aber wie haben wir immer gesagt, wir gehen den Weg so, dass wir unseren Körper dafür hergeben, was hätten wir noch länger gespielt, definitiv weiter gemacht hätten. Dann soll sich das auch finanziell so entlohnen, dass ich gerne bereit bin, mal auf Skifahren zu verzichten, dass ich mit meinen Kindern, wenn ich sie mal haben sollte, nicht so umherrennen kann, wie vielleicht manch anderer noch oder mit 30, 35 jetzt nicht so fit bin, wie manch anderer. Und da muss ich ganz klar – auch wieder drehen wir uns wieder um dieses gleiche Thema – da müssen die Verantwortlichen wirklich aktiv sein und eigentlich auch horchen gucken können. Weil, sag mal, im 15-jährigen das erste Mal sich in den Oberschenkel reißt, wär grad besser, wenn du mal ein bisschen länger pausierst. Dieses Kennenlernen mit Verletzungen, man kommt eigentlich als – man kennt keine Verletzungen, man kennt sich als Unkaputtbar. Ich kenn auch die Phasen, wo ich quasi ohne Aufwärm auf den Platz und rumrenne und schieße, wo ich mir heute denke, ey Junge, du musst dich mindestens 45 Minuten warm machen, bevor du ein Pass spielst. Man lernt das ja. Und das wird ja dann auch ganz lustig. U15, Ersichtungsturnier für die Nationalmannschaft bei Westfalen. Ja, ich wär mich auf und werd noch am Platz, am Rücken behandelt, werd ich noch eingeregnet, damit ich wieder auf dem Platz dann fit bin. Ja, Marius mit Fragen, kannst du spielen? Ja, wo ich mal ein Faszienriss hatte, in der U16, wo ich bemerkt, kam der Trainer auf mich zu, wann willst du fit? Wir spielen zwei Wochen gegen Schalke. So nach dem Motto, genau da, wo ich sag, jetzt im Nachhinein, Leute, ihr seid erwachsene Männer oder Frauen, jeder dem, aber natürlich meistens Männer. Ihr sprecht hier gerade mit einem 16-Jährigen, tretet mal einen Schritt zurück, es ist ein U16-Spiel, es ist ein U15-Spiel, es geht um die Entwicklung, um die langjährige Entwicklung. Es ist mal okay, wenn da mal ein Spiel ausfällt. Ja, auch dieses, um jeden Preis. Wir kennen eigentlich keinen Spieler U19, da gibt es ganz wenige, die verletzungsfrei, bis dahin… Gibt's gar nicht, würde ich mal sagen. Echt, bis dahin noch. Also die, die immer gespielt haben. Ja, das ist auch gut. Aber wenn man auch mal sagt, Leute, mach doch mal ein bisschen Belastungssteuerung, dann muss man aber irgendwie über das Thema Erfolg sprechen, ja? Dann ist es, musst du auch mal bereit sein, vielleicht Spieler Nummer 15, 16, 17 spielen zu lassen und nicht deine Top-11 auf den Platz zu schicken, wo der eine die die die Beine schon getapet hat oder mit einem Schmerzabweite spielt, dann verliert man mal schlecht weg. Ja, auch wenn das vielleicht falsch klingt und man sagt, man ist wieder verbeichlich. Aber da hat man eigentlich die Verantwortung, man sagt, Leute, kriegt man wieder ein bisschen Bezug zur Realität, das ist ein U16 Spiel oder U17 Spiel. Es ist schön, wenn wir gewinnen, wenn er auf dem Platz ist, aber es wäre noch besser, wenn er fit bleibt, ja? Also es ist auch ganz oft so, dass man ja guckt, also ich kann mir jetzt niemals vorstellen, dreimal die Woche zu spielen, also über zehn Jahre, wo wir jetzt quasi U17 und U19 Jahre, groß Niveau auf Junioreneben, aber dann noch mal jede Woche Bundesliga spielen, vielleicht Pokal dabei, vielleicht sogar Champions League oder International, also was da abgerufen wird, da war bei mir zum Beispiel ganz viele, die wir kennen, der Körper schon eigentlich so blästiert, dass sie gar nicht, oder wenn damit ganz viel Physio und so weiter da durchkommen, ja also bis zur U19, wenn man dann raus ist, da hat jeder mal eine größere Sache, das heißt die Hüfte kaputt, das heißt mal, das Knie, jeder hat irgendwas, jeder geht hoch in den Fitnessraum und hat sein kleines Päckchen, was er da bearbeitet und da denkt man sich auch so, ja Thema Belastungssteuerung, ja lass sie mal einfach ein bisschen holen, ja also das Belastungssteuerung war eigentlich nicht, da ging es um jeden Preis zu gewinnen, wenn du fit warst und so, auch wenn du halbwegs nur fit warst, wenn du halbwegs nur fit warst und ein wichtiges Spiel war, dann war das halt, wie bei den Profis, wie Stefan gesagt hat, dieses Triple Down, bei den Profis wird es auch gemacht, aber da geht es um 20 Millionen, Ja, das ist ein Thema. Und wenn du vom Viertelfinale ins Halbfinale kommst, in den Champions League, dann geht es um viel Geld. Dann ist es auch okay, wenn der Verantwortliche immer sagt, du, beist du mal auf die 10, wir brauchen das und wir wollen das. Aber in der Jugend, ob ich jetzt Westfalen-Pokalsieger werde, also im extremen Beispiel, das ist ja.
Ja, und gleichzeitig, also die Spielbelastung ist hoch. Ich meine, ihr habt ja noch eine Youth League dann auch gespielt, also dem Champions League-Bondon, wo man, wo man auch, also man ist in so einer ständigen Ambivalenz. Also ihr erzählt ja auch von Turnieren in Dubai und in Russland, die WM mit Lothar Matthäus, der da auch sich ganz vorbildlich verhalten hat gegenüber den, Schutzbefohlenen ist zu viel, aber den Jugendlichen. Lest das Buch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es ist eine der schönen Anekdoten an dieser Stelle. Also eine, die man sich zumindest erinnert. Also auf der einen Seite ist es ja auch toll, weil das ist ja auch etwas, was man zurückbekommt. Ihr gebt sehr viel in diesem jungen Alter und ihr bekommt diese Reisen. Ihr seht auch mehr von der Welt als ganz viele andere Jugendliche. Und gleichzeitig ist es aber auch wieder ein kleines Mosaiksteinchen, was eben diesen Druck erhöht. Es sind eben noch mehr Spiele. Es sind gerade diese Turniere. Da ist auch immer der Erfolg sehr gut ablesbar. Also ich verstehe das. Ich habe ja selber früher auch Turniere gespielt. Es muss einen Sieger geben, aber vielleicht ist das auch nicht immer der perfekte Ansatz. Vielleicht kann man das auch mal anders gestalten. Also ich war ganz oft beim Junior Cup in Sindelfingen vor Ort. Da ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass sie einen Turnierbaum so gemacht haben, dass jedes Team am Ende die gleiche Anzahl Spieler hat, egal wie schlecht du abgeschnitten hast in der Gruppenphase. So eine kleine Sache, die sie da verändert haben, dass da schon mal ein bisschen der Druck raus ist. Auch wenn man da auch schon gesehen hat, da habe ich auch Verhaltensweisen gesehen von Trainern ihren Teams, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Junge, du bist hier in Sindelfingen. Komm mal runter, auch wenn es vielleicht auf Sport 1 übertragen wird. Aber das ist eben das und das bringt mich zu so einem großen Überpunkt, nämlich die Ambivalenz, die dieses gesamte Thema durchzieht. Man will jungen Menschen ihren Traum nicht nehmen. Man will ihnen eigentlich auch alles zur Verfügung stellen, dass sie es in den Profifußball schaffen. Und wir haben auch auf der anderen Seite und schon darüber beschwert, warum können die alle nichts, die im Profifußball ankommen. Also wir, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, wollen ja auch dann, dass Deutschland auch einen erfolgreichen Fußball spielt. Und auf der anderen Seite wissen wir aber auch alle, die Realität sagt, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, es ist extrem schwierig und man muss vielleicht, man verliert vielleicht mehr auf der Strecke, als es dann letztlich schaffen. Plus, eine Klammer muss ich jetzt noch setzen, das habe ich nämlich gerade noch vergessen, der ganze Bereich des Mädchenfußballs ist in dem Fall noch mal krasser, weil die mit schlechteren Bedingungen spielen und aber verletzungsanfälliger für so richtige Hardcore-Verletzungen wie Kreuzbandrisse sind. Riesiges Thema, sehen wir, es kommt jetzt gerade endlich im Frauenfußball, wird drüber berichtet, weil, also weil leider sich richtig tolle Spielerinnen jetzt vor der WM wieder die Kreuzbände gerissen haben. Aber da geht es ja im Jugendfußball auch schon los, also auch noch ganz wichtiger Aspekt, den man nicht vergessen darf. Aber zurück zu dieser Ambivalenz. Und diese Ambivalenz kann man ja letztlich dann runterbrechen auf 1% schafft es in dem Profi-Fußball, 99% schaffen es nicht. Was machen die 99% danach? Hoffentlich haben sie irgendwie einen Schulabschluss hinbekommen. Jetzt habe ich mit euch zwei dieser 99% hier sitzen, also nicht zwei Prozent, sondern zwei, die innerhalb dieser 99% sind. Wie denkt ihr denn jetzt zurück an diese Zeit, wenn ihr jetzt auch darüber nachdenkt, dass ihr seid mit weitem Abstand die Jüngsten in dieser Runde hier? Ihr habt noch am meisten Leben vor euch. Wie zufrieden seid ihr damit, wie ihr das quasi geschafft habt, das auszutarieren?
Sehr zufrieden tatsächlich. Klar, dieser harte Cut, von dem ich werde meinen Traum nie erreichen, die Erkenntnis dazu bekommen und sich das selber einzugestehen, das war ganz schlimm. Diese letzten Wochen, die ich vor allem in Dortmund und in der U19 hatte, waren schon total hart. Einfach nur Scheiße. Und dieser Prozess bis hin zur Entscheidung, ich höre jetzt auf, das ist jetzt hier gerade ein ganz harter Cut, aber das ist ein Cut, weil es einfach nicht mehr das ist und niemals das werden wird, was ich wollte, das war sehr schwierig, auch sehr anspruchsvoll für den Kopf. Da geht einem natürlich auch viel durch den Kopf. Ist das jetzt schon das Richtige oder ist das ein klassisches Ich gebe jetzt hier gerade ein bisschen zu früh auf vielleicht in dem Moment, aber als ich dann wirklich meinen Vertrag da mal aufgelöst habe und gesagt habe, so jetzt ist das Ende, das war dann total befreiend und quasi ab dem Punkt muss ich echt sagen, an wurde es von Tag zu Tag nur besser. Also da war ich echt jeden Tag oder ich bin jeden Tag immer mehr im Reinen mit mir, dass ich das so entschieden habe und dass ich auch in spiel gucken kann und jetzt im Endeffekt sagen kann, ja okay, ich war nicht gut genug für das, was ich erreichen wollte. Es gab Umstände, die hätten es erleichtern können, es gab leider Umstände, die haben das insgesamt alles erschwert, aber ich kann in spiel gucken und im Großen und Ganzen sagen, okay, für das, was ich erreichen wollte, war ich nicht gut genug. Und die Erkenntnis zu bekommen und zu erhalten hat sehr geholfen. Das hat mir persönlich sehr geholfen, habe ich auch gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht schlimm. So, das Leben geht weiter, ich habe zum Glück mein Abi gemacht, ich kann jetzt danach alles machen, was ich wollte. Und seit dem Tag geht es mir damit sehr gut und ich bin damit, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, sehr zufrieden. Die Entscheidung würde ich, auf die würde ich genauso, genauso wieder treffen. Also bei mir ist es genauso. Bisschen länger gedauert, aber jetzt so im Großen und Ganzen so sagen zu können, man ist sehr zufrieden. Da gibt man so eine ganze Lebensanstellung, sag ich mal, so wie wir jetzt sind, wir sind angekommen, ein paar Daboren zusammen, wir studieren was Gutes, jeweils natürlich der andere. Ich mache jetzt keine Steuerbewertung, aber man fühlt sich, man ist angekommen und auch dieser ganze Prozess und vielleicht auch immer die Frage, ein bisschen weiter zu sagen, wir sind, wir würden es wieder tun, also auch jetzt ich mit meinem Bandscheinvorfall, ich glaube nur mit deinem Leisten und so weiter, man kann alle Sachen nehmen, auch mit dem Scheitern, wenn man es einen Scheitern nennen möchte. Der Weg war genial, ja auch das, was wir versuchen natürlich auch im Buch wiederzugeben, all die schönen Sachen, die waren schon ziemlich, ziemlich geil. Also das muss man erstmal so sagen und auch erleben können und klingt natürlich immer ein bisschen doof, aber wir haben aber gesagt, ey, wir sind 22 und können 250 Seiten füllen, was wir einfach erlebt haben. Und das ist schon, das ist einfach ganz cool, wo man sagt, das möchte man nicht missen und da haben wir auch ganz viel rausgenommen, die wir jetzt halt auch heute nutzen können, also die wir auch einfach ein bisschen ja schon ins normale, ins Berufsleben vielleicht mitnehmen können. Also Beispiel, wir haben es schon mal gehört, dass jemand zu einem sagt, du bist nicht gut genug. Ja, also es reicht nicht, such dir was anderes, ja, wo man vielleicht mal sagen kann, okay, wie geht man mit so was um, was vielleicht in der heutigen Welt auch mit häufigeren Jobwechseln vielleicht zu tun hat. Ja, aber wie geht man mit Niederlagen um, wie geht man damit um, wenn jemand sagt, du geh mal lieber. Auch Entscheidungen treffen, wir sind glaube ich beide ziemlich, ja doch, stolz kann man schon sagen in dem Sinn, dass man aktiv zu sich selber sagen kann, okay, möchtest du das noch oder nicht und aktiv eine Entscheidung zu treffen. Weil ganz viele sind ja auch gut, die sind vielleicht auch angewiesen, weil das Geld ja auch nicht verkehrt ist. Die spielen jetzt vierte, fünfte Liga, sind 23, 24, 25, haben immer noch die Hoffnung, kommen ein gutes Spiel, dann komme ich in die zweite, dann muss ich Scout sitzen und vielleicht schaffe ich noch den Sprung und werde Profi und sickern so langsam dahin und ruht ab wirklich Respekt für jeden, der ein Fernstudium macht oder danach mit 28, 27 sich nochmal auf die Vorlesungsbank irgendwo setzt oder irgendwo eine Ausbildung anfängt. Das muss man erstmal auch machen. Da sind wir stolz, dass wir gesagt haben, also wir waren sehr, sehr weit weg zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo wir oft gehört haben vom Profi-Fußball, wo wir gesagt haben, da wollen wir hin und da dann sich selber zu sagen, es macht glaube ich gerade mehr Sinn, was anderes zu machen. Das war ganz gut eigentlich und den bereuen wir auch nicht. Ja, es hört sich immer so dramatisch an, wenn man sagt, wir haben uns aktiv damit abgefunden, dass wir gescheitert sind. Das hört sich immer so schlimm an, aber eigentlich ist es das Gegenteil.
Ihr gehört ja jetzt nur zu uns. Also Stefan und ich haben es auch nie in die Bundesliga geschafft. Also ihr gehört zur Mehrheit jetzt.
Ja, aber der Punkt ist ja, wenn man mal ganz endlich ist, ist es auch ein Fall, wir hätten ja weitermachen können. Ja, also oft ist es ja auch in ganz vielen Situationen, da kann man ja vielleicht jeder mal, hat jeder ein Beispiel im Kopf, aber wo man Entscheidungen abgibt, wenn ich jetzt im Studium zum Beispiel, wenn ich die dritte Klausur jetzt vorbei haue, dann ist es so, dann breche ich das Studium ab. Muss ich ja eh abbrechen, beispielsweise so. Als wir hätten ja noch einen Verein bekommen, also dann sei es fünfte Liga oder selbst sechste Liga oder irgendwo, wir wären ja wo untergekommen, hätten wir auch weitermachen können, jetzt probieren wir es. Irgendwann, irgendwann, irgendwann mit 28, ich sage dann irgendwie, komm, bei mir reicht es auch nicht, dann ist Karriereende und dann wird die Entscheidung so ein bisschen abgenommen. Ja, man probiert es immer weiter. Obwohl der Zug, wenn man ganz ehrlich zu sich selber ist, vielleicht schon, ja, abgebogen ist zu der großen Karriere. Klar, es gibt die Spätzünder, aber das ist dann unter dem 1% nochmal dieser 0, 1%ig Anteil, der da so ist. Und das wollen wir mit Entscheidungen treffen, wo wir dann quasi, wir hätten das auch so, ich sage mal, dahin sicken lassen können, so ein bisschen und nun weiterkriegen. Aber da hätte man, da mussten wir ja aktiv nein sagen, weil dann haben wir gesagt, auch zum Berater gehen und sagen, du, such uns keinen neuen Verein, den Eltern Bescheid geben, wir gehen was anderes ein, der Familie das zu sagen. Das ist ja wirklich eine Entscheidung treffen. Das ist nicht mal so eben. Das ist, man muss da quasi aktiv einmal Stopp sagen und der Zug hält, weil der würde sonst einfach weiterholen.
Und weil es jetzt schon gerade angesprochen habt, das ist jetzt ein Aspekt, den haben wir so ein bisschen beiseite liegen lassen, die Peripherie, die ihr auch dann um Jugendspieler wie euch sich aufgebaut hat. Also ihr hattet eben Ausrüsteverträge zum Beispiel. Also zu dem 4-Jahres-Vertrag war damals auch ein Ausrüstevertrag mit, was bedeutet, geh mal hier in den Shop rein und suche für dich und deine Familie, nimm alles mit, was du haben möchtest und das passt dann schon. Und eben auch Berater, die sich ja schon sehr früh melden. Das habt ihr im Buch ja auch beschrieben, dass die sich zum Teil, also die seriöseren melden sich bei den Eltern, gibt aber auch genügend, die einen einfach so über soziale Netzwerke anschreiben und sagen, hey, soll ich dir Tickets für Spiele besorgen und so weiter? Willst du ein neues Paar Fußballschuhe haben und so weiter und so fort? Wie habt ihr denn dieses ganze Drumherum wahrgenommen, was ja auch passiert in einem Moment, wo man das noch nicht reflektieren kann? Also wie soll ein 14- 15-jähriger Junge oder Mädchen das reflektieren, was hier gerade passiert, wenn so viele Leute auf einmal von dir etwas wollen und die auch sagen, du bist toll und ich helfe dir, noch besser zu werden und so weiter und so fort? Wie blickt ihr da jetzt mit ein bisschen Abstand drauf?
Ja, das ist natürlich schon, wenn man das so sagt, wenn ich jetzt mit 23 drüber nachdenke, ich hatte mit 14 Vertrag bei Dortmund und ein Ausrüstvertrag bei Pruma, da sag ich ja jetzt selber schon zu meinem Ich vor den Jahren, das ist ja eigentlich total direlle, totale Parallelwelt. Was mir immer geholfen hat, ist erstmal natürlich, wenn die Eltern einen da immer auf den Boden halten und sagen so, das ist hier alles immer nur halblang, das passt schon alles, aber cool bleiben. Und was mir persönlich am meisten geholfen hat, war, dass es immer weiter ging. Es gab das nächste Spiel, es gab sofort das nächste Training und wieder das nächste Spiel, das nächste Turnier. Also diese Zeit zum Reflektieren, vielleicht ist es sogar auch gut, dass das ein 14-Jähriger gar nicht kann und gar keine Zeit dafür hat, weil der einfach dran bleiben muss. Und man wurde ja dadurch, dass es so ein voller Terminkalender war, immer in seine Welt da reingedrückt.
Also ist die Spielbelastung doch gut.
Ja, also auch mit 14 Jahren ist es einfach gut, wenn du was zu tun hast. Wenn du natürlich jetzt den Vertrag bekommst und hast dann nach drei Wochen Urlaub und kannst drei Wochen darüber nachdenken, wie toll du eigentlich bist, was du jetzt hier erreicht hast, dann wird es natürlich schwierig. Aber in dem Zusammenhang für den Kopf war das für mich total gut, dass es immer weiter ging. Man musste sich ja immer weiter beweisen, es kam wieder das nächste Spiel. Ein Ausrüstervertrag hilft einem dann auch nichts, wenn man dann die nächsten sechs Wochen nur schlecht trainiert und nicht mehr spielt. Da kann man zwar die neuesten Schuhe anhaben, nur wenn man mit den Schuhen nicht auf dem Platz steht, ist es natürlich schwierig. Deswegen war das für mich immer gut, dass ich wusste, es geht weiter und es geht die ganze Zeit weiter. Und es steht ja auch im Buch wirklich toll so drin als Metapher. Das ist ein jahrelanger Tunnelblick. Dieser jahrelange Tunnelblick, der hat mir da immer sehr geholfen.
Von Spiel zu Spiel gedacht, wie die ganz Großen.
Ja, es hört sich immer so zu einer Floskel an, aber das stimmt ja. Ja, vor allem, man guckt ja nicht nur von sich selber, dass man selber von Spiel zu Spiel guckt. Jeder guckt von Spiel zu Spiel. Ja, also das haben wir auch in der Jugend mitbekommen. Da gibt es teilweise Phasen, da bist du quasi raus, auch aus den Sichtungsmaßnahmen. Dann spielst du drei Spiele gut und um einmal bist du wieder ganz oben mit dabei. Das ist ja auch in der Jugend schnell lebendig. Also da kann man drei gute Spiele haben und sagen, boah, was ist das jetzt für einer? Der kickt gerade richtig gut, den müssen wir mal weiter auf den Zettel halten. Und dann kommt der Boomer-Vertrag und dann die nächsten drei Spiele nur Quatsch spielen und arrogant sein und sich ausruhen auf den Norbernenblättern. Dann ist ja auch ganz schön gesagt, was ist das denn für einer? Was hat der denn für einen Vertrag bekommen und was soll das denn? Und dann wird hinterfragt. So und deswegen ist das ganz gut, weil man selber einfach Gas gämt. Man macht weiter. Und ein gutes Umfeld, da hat man Glück mit Eltern und so. Also wir können es gar nicht vorstellen, möchte ich auch gar nicht. Wenn wir da ein bisschen alleine wären, ich glaube, da ist der Drang, auch mal ein bisschen abzuheben, kann schnell passieren, wenn ich in die Schule reingehen würde mit den neuesten Puma-Klamotten und mir neben mir die Mitschüler nerven und ich so, ey, was willst du von mir, guck mal da drüber. So kann auch schnell passieren mit der Pubertät, war zum Glück nicht so.
Und es kann ja auch genau andersherum sein. Also es geht ja nicht nur um Abheben, sondern es kann auch sein, dass man vielleicht in diesem Tunnelblick den eigentlichen Plan A komplett aus dem Blick verliert. Also zu sehr an den Profifußball glaubt und nur als kleine Fußnote, die eigentlich gar keine kleine Fußnote sein sollte. Aber wir sprechen jetzt hier gerade über euren Weg und über unseren Blick auf das Ganze. Laut Studien gibt es rund 15.000 Spieler, die pro Jahr alleine aus Afrika in den europäischen Jugendfußball geholt werden. Das ist nur Afrika pro Jahr 15.000 Spieler. Da gibt es ja auch, da werde ich auch eine Doku verlinken, wo eben auch das Zitatfreund von Professor Dr. Arne Güllich rauskommt. Es gibt quasi noch eine komplett weitere Dimension. Wir reden jetzt hier über Menschen, die von Dresden nach Dortmund gezogen sind, kurz nach Nürnberg. Kann man im Buch alles nachlesen. Das ist aber halt nochmal ein Unterschied, weil man kennt das Land, man hat eine Peripherie, man hat Leute, die einem helfen. Es gibt noch einen kompletten Schwarm an Jugendspielern, die für diesen Traum den Kontinent wechseln und hier komplett alleine sitzen und die dann aber auch einfach fallen gelassen werden, so ähnlich wie ihr manchmal auch aussortiert wurdet. Also es gibt viele Abstellgleismetaphern in eurem Buch. Und für euch war aber immer dann auch ein Netz da, was euch noch helfen konnte. Und ihr habt ja jetzt auch, wenn ihr so einen versöhnlichen Blick auf das habt, dann ist es wunderbar und es ist toll. Aber wir dürfen das eben nicht komplett aus dem Blick verlieren. Es gibt da leider noch viel, viel gravierende Geschichten, wo ja viel schlimmere Dinge noch passieren. Und auch davon, also das ist eben Teil dieses Systems Fußball, dass wir irgendwie auch alle toll finden und wir gucken ja gerne Fußball. Und wir drei, vier, wie sind da vier, fällt mir gerade ein, lieben ja auch den Fußball. Aber es gibt dann noch eine komplett andere Ebene. Und das bringt mich zum allerletzten Thema, mit dem wir dann, auch wenn ich echt noch ewig mit euch weiter reden könnte, aber so langsam will ich euch ja auch in euren Feiertag entlassen. Aber da würde ich dich gerne, Stefan, noch mit reinholen. Nämlich zu der Frage, naja, was machen wir denn jetzt mit den Dingen, die wir jetzt so diskutiert haben? Und du hast ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, wir haben ja auch schon ein bisschen das andiskutiert. Der DFB hat Reformen auf den Weg gebracht, sowohl im Jugendfußball als auch zum Beispiel in der Trainerausbildung. Magst du mal vielleicht kurz deine Gedanken zusammenfassen? Was soll sich denn eigentlich verändern im deutschen Fußball? Und jetzt vor allem dem, was wir hier besprochen haben, wie würdest du das bewerten?
Also was soll sich verändern? Ich finde, der DFB hat auf verschiedensten Ebenen gute Ideen, die er versucht umzusetzen. Da kann man darüber streiten, ob – ich habe es ja vorhin schon mal kurz angesprochen – ob von Inyo jetzt das alleinige Spielmodell sein soll für die ganz Kleinen. Das sehe ich auch nicht so, aber zumindest als Zusatzoption ist es absolut gerechtfertigt. Die Wettbewerbsreform, dass quasi die A-Jugend und B-Jugend Bundesliga abgelöst werden durch eine Art Turniermodus, wie er in England gespielt wird, muss man dazu sagen, dass die Jugendmannschaften das nicht kennen, dass man Spiele gegeneinander spielt, die nachher in der Tabelle aufgerechnet werden und dann gibt es einen Meister und einen Absteiger, sondern die verabreden sich am Wochenende zu einem Turnier, der FC Arsenal mit dem FC Chelsea und noch fünf anderen, und dann spielen die da quasi den ganzen Tag Fußball oder vielleicht auf zwei Tage Fußball und dann gehen die wieder auseinander. Also ohne diesen Gewinnendruck, den wir jetzt auch schon oft genug angesprochen haben, da kann man darüber streiten, weil da gibt es natürlich Leute, die sagen ja, aber woher sollen die dann lernen, dann zu gewinnen, wo kommt die Mentalität her und so weiter. Also es gibt Pro und Contra, genauso bei der Trainerausbildung, die jetzt tatsächlich schon reformiert ist seit, glaube ich, zwei Jahren mittlerweile, das haben sie relativ schnell durchgeboxt. Da sind gute Sachen dabei, das wird jetzt noch ein bisschen, also noch deutlich mehr aufgeteilt, als es vorher war. Vorher gab es Grassroots, C-Lizenz, B-Lizenz, DFB Elite, damit man am NLZ trainieren darf und die A-Lizenz und dann natürlich den Fußballlehrer darüber. Jetzt wurde noch mal feiner unterteilt und auch sehr, die Ausbildung wird jetzt ein bisschen spezifischer auch. Also ein großes Problem war tatsächlich, dass man viele A-Lizenz-Trainer hatte, die natürlich in ihrer Ausbildung für Seniorenfußball ausgebildet wurden, die haben aber nachher eine C-Jugend trainiert. Also die Kinder mit völlig falschen Voraussetzungen, mit völlig falschen Erwartungshaltungen auch ran und stülpen wieder dieses Erwachsenen-Denken auf 14-Jährige um. Und das ist natürlich, das geht im seltensten Fall, geht das dann gut. Das Problem bei der neuen Trainerausbildung ist jetzt aber aus meiner Sicht, und das höre ich auch immer wieder jetzt von Leuten, die sich damit beschäftigen oder auch da rein wollen in dieses System, dass die Eintrittsschwelle, die ist jetzt teilweise so hoch, dass sich das keiner mehr sowohl finanziell als auch zeitlich leisten kann. Also wenn ich jetzt eine A-Lizenz machen wollte vor drei Jahren, dann hätte mich das, ich meine, vier bis sechs Wochen Ausbildungszeit gekostet, die ich mir dann halt nehmen muss als berufstätiger Urlaub nehmen. Und so über den Daumen vielleicht 2.000 bis 3.000 Euro, so um den Drehdruck, also schon ordentlich Geld, aber vielleicht übernimmt der Verein das Jahr, zumindest teilweise. Jetzt ist es so, dass man noch mehr Zeit investieren muss, dass der Kurs, ich glaube, 6.000 oder 8.000 Euro kostet. Und vor allen Dingen, dass es so eine Art Credit-Point-System gibt, wo du sehr viel mit deiner Vorleistung, in der Regel als Spieler, dafür einzahlst, damit du überhaupt erst in diesen Kurs kommst, also in diesen Lehrgang kommst. Das heißt, Spieler, die unterhalb der Oberliga gespielt haben, die können sich nicht 20 Punkte im Credit-Point-System an sich gut schreiben lassen, das geht gar nicht. Die haben schon mal einen unglaublich schweren Start, überhaupt diese Grenze zu überschreiten, um in diesen Lehrgang zu kommen. So geht es schon los. Oder Menschen, die kein Sportwissenschaftsschulium haben, so wie ich zum Beispiel. Wenn das einer nicht hat, das würden mir jetzt angerechnet werden, ich glaube mit fünf Punkten oder mit zehn oder noch Zusatzqualifikation. Wenn man das alles nicht hat, dann wird es wirklich schwierig. Also da hat man jetzt quasi drei Faktoren, die dich dermaßen einschränken oder die den Zugang von Normalos dermaßen einschränken, dass die eine B-Plus-Lizenz, wie sie mittlerweile heißt, fürs NRZ oder für ihren Stützpunkt gar nicht mehr machen können. Und das verstehe ich nicht. Also der Kreis an Leuten, die ausgeschlossen werden, hat sich auf diesem Trainer-Level aus meiner Sicht eher vergrößert, als dass er kleiner wird. Und das kann einfach nicht der Sinn der Übung sein. Die anderen Sachen, da kann man darüber diskutieren, da sind bestimmt gute Dinge dabei. Aber das finde ich, das ist nicht so besonders gut gelöst. Und das höre ich auch immer wieder von Leuten, die am Stützpunkt arbeiten, dass das einfach den Nachschub an neuen Trainer dann auch irgendwann erschwert. Was sich noch ändern sollte, also wir haben jetzt oft genug über Ambivalenz gesprochen und über Vor- und Nachteile und Pro- und Kontra. Und genau das ist es halt auch leider. Also es gibt für jeden, für jedes Argument oder für jede Entscheidung gibt es gute Argumente und sehr valide Argumente, aber genauso gibt es sie dagegen auch. Und es wird wahrscheinlich schwierig sein, immer alle Seiten zufrieden stellen zu können. Das wird nicht passen, das werden wir nicht hinkriegen. Egal, wer das versucht jetzt umzusetzen, das wird nicht funktionieren. Aber wenn ich mir was wünschen könnte, dann wäre es tatsächlich so, dass wir in Deutschland aufhören auf diesem hohen Rost zu sitzen, sowohl was das Land als Zeug betrifft, um zu sagen, wir wissen schon wie es läuft, als auch – und das ist wirklich ein wichtiger Punkt, den ich hier gerne anbringen würde – wir müssen auch aufhören als Sportartfußball immer zu denken, wir machen alles super top und wir sind hier die Instanz und alle anderen um uns herum in anderen Sportarten sind voll blind oder halb blind. Das ist dermaßen falsch gedacht, dass es wirklich schon weh tut. Und die paar Trainer, die sich die Mühe machen, mal in andere Sportarten zu gucken oder sich mit Trainern aus anderen Sportarten zu unterhalten, die werden auf Dauer besser werden. Und das müssen die deutschen Trainer für sich selber auch zulassen, dass sie diesen Input von außen sich auch selbst, wenn es ihnen schon nicht vorgelegt wird, selbst holen. Weil so wie das momentan so dieses engstündige und nur auf einer Ebene zu funktionieren, das ist bei Spielern schlecht. Das wird jeder Trainer sagen, was kann der Junge mit einem Zehnjährigen, was macht der für Sport? Der spielt Fußball? Okay, ist gut, der spielt Superfußball. Macht der vielleicht noch was anders? Kann der Skifahren? Kann der Basketball spielen? Kann der Rollschuh laufen? Ist der multisportiv? Das bringt unheimlich viel, weil der ein anderes Bewegungslernen hat, eine andere Motorik entwickeln kann. Der kennt andere Sachen. Der weiß, dass er beim Basketball, wenn er einen Ball in die Hand bekommt, genau noch drei Schritte laufen darf oder stehen bleiben muss. Und da muss eine Aktion erfolgen. Und dieses Über-den-Teller-ran-hinausschauen, das fehlt aus meiner Sicht immer noch. Und das ist so ein softer Skill, da muss man nichts können. Da muss man einfach nur bereit sein, andere Dinge zuzulassen. Das würde ich mir wünschen.
Das ist eigentlich genau das, was wir ja versucht haben. Ich muss einen tollen Zusammenfass wieder, Stefan, weil das war das, was wir versucht haben, mit diesem Teller ran. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig. Es gibt viele Sachen mit Pro und Contra, wo man diskutieren kann. Auf der einen Seite aber das mit dieser Führungsperson, Trainer, dass sich da was ändern sollte, bzw. dass da mal drüber geguckt wird, wie geht man mit Jugendspielern um, wie geht man an die Sache ran. Da kann man glaube ich wenig diskutieren, wenn man sich mit dem Thema auskennt, bzw. das auch mal hinterfragt, dass sich da was ändern sollte. Das stimmt. Und genau wie du sagst, ob das jetzt weniger um Gewinn geht, jetzt mit England, ob man so ein System nimmt oder nicht, oder ob man das ganz anders macht, darum geht es ja uns gar nicht. Oder das wünschen wir uns gar nicht. Was eigentlich der Punkt ist, was toll wäre, ist, wenn man anfängt wieder Sachen zu hinterfragen. Und da sind wir wieder bei diesen Scheuklappen und dieses, das haben wir immer schon gemacht, was wir am Anfang gesagt haben. Dieses vom Ross runtergehende, das trifft es super, dass man sagt, man ein bisschen demütig ist, mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und sagen, wir sind gerade nicht die Spitze, sei es fußballerisch, DFB-mäßig oder auch von der Sportart her. Ja, es geht darum zu diskutieren und selbst wenn man Sachen beibehält, aber sie mal wenigstens hinterfragt, ist es der aktuelle Stand, den wir verfolgen wollen. Da gibt es ganz viele Möglichkeiten, über die man mal diskutieren kann. Du hast Stefan angesprochen, wie man in der Jugend die Spielform betreibt. Ist es sinnvoll, dass man mit zehn anfängt, jeden Tag nur Fußball zu spielen? Ist es gut für die Hauberschenkel? Ist es gut für die Knie? Macht es nicht mal Sinn, was anderes zu machen, andere Bewegungsmuster reinzukriegen? Mal ein bisschen – jeder Fußballer, den man sich anguckt, ist verkürzt hinten. Kann man da was machen? Mal einfach als Idee, mal zu sagen, wo ich zum Beispiel mal drüber gestolpert bin, einfach mal auch als Gedankenexperiment. Keiner wundert sich, dass es einen Torvertrainer gibt. Aber es gibt keinen Verteidigung oder keinen Fäherkettentrainer, es gibt auf einmal einen Einwurftrainer. Mal so was zum Beispiel, mal kleinere Gruppen denken. Mal gucken, wie ist wirklich, weil es da natürlich noch um Athletik geht, wenn man Football-Fan ist, American Football, wie sind die in der Athletik da aufgestellt? Wie kann man da was optimieren? Wie machen die das? Wie sind das andere Sportarten, die vielleicht nicht so die Geldressourcen haben mit anderen Sportarten, wie machen die das? Das ist, glaube ich, genau das, um das jetzt abzufangen, was Stefan gesagt hat, und aufzunehmen. Einfach bereit sein, mal Sachen zu hinterfragen und auch mal neue Dinge aufzunehmen, zu evaluieren. Bringt es was? Bringt es uns was vorwärts? Mal zu diskutieren. Und nicht einfach in den Muster verhalten und verbleiben, die man hat, weil man es immer schon gemacht hat, weil es bequem ist. Man kann ja Sachen wieder verwerfen. Genau wie wenn man sagt, der Utova-Trainer ist super, aber ein Verteidigungstrainer, wenn man die Ressource braucht, braucht man nicht. Kann man ja wieder wegschmeißen, aber mal darüber diskutieren, mal Sachen versuchen, einfach mal in Frage zu stellen. Und das fehlt dann schon. Da muss man dann sagen, klar gibt es dann kein richtig und falsch. Aber man muss dann da rausfinden und gucken, was wollen wir jetzt und dann sind wir wieder bei dem Thema Umsetzen. Weil was wir jetzt entscheiden, haben wir erst in 15 Jahren, 10 Jahren, 20 Jahren. Die jungen Spieler, wenn der DFB jetzt eine Entscheidung trifft, dann freut er sich 2040 über, was weiß ich nicht, was da ist, ob es ein Nationalteam ist oder WM. Da kann er sich dann darüber freuen. Das muss man dann einfach mal entscheiden und dann auch dabei behalten. Einfach mal die Augen aufmachen.
Und weniger Angst vor Fehlern haben. Also das, was man ja auch auf dem Spielfeld, vor allem im Juniorenfußball, auch gerne hätte. Mach auch mal die Sache, die du gerade im Kopf hast, auch wenn sie schief geht. Das kann man auch auf struktureller Ebene sehen. Da braucht man sich ja nur die deutsche Infrastruktur angucken. Als letzte Frage will ich aber nochmal das nutzen, dass ich vermute, dass diese Sendungen ja auch Hörerinnen und Hörer hören oder bei YouTube sehen, die vielleicht jetzt gerade noch in diesem NLZ und Juniorenfußball drinstecken. Gibt es etwas, Marius, Alex, was ihr denjenigen mitgeben wollen würdet?
Auf jeden Fall darf der Spaß niemals verloren gehen. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was wir uns am Ende so ein bisschen auch gedacht haben im Nachhinein. Das ist manchmal, dass man da echt selber ein bisschen zu verkopft war und zu streng mit sich selber und allem. Also sobald es anfängt, dass der Spaß wirklich komplett verloren geht, dann ist das ein ganz falscher Weg. Das hört sich immer so einfach an und man sagt das immer so, verlier den Spaß nicht, aber das ist wirklich ein ganz essenzieller Punkt, dass man sich da manchmal dran besinnt, warum man überhaupt angefangen hat, Fußball zu spielen und warum man das alles macht. Und sonst würde ich einfach sagen, dass echt versuchen zu genießen und das alles aufzusaugen, weil das schon eine besondere, schöne Zeit ist und sich da einfach nicht verschließen vor irgendwas. Das wären so Sachen, die hätte ich, glaube ich, gerne garmals in meiner aktiven Zeit ein bisschen mehr gemacht, mich da ein bisschen mehr drauf besonnen. Ja, weil das hätte ein bisschen geholfen, glaube ich, im Nachhinein, ja. Ja, wir haben über, dass man früh in die Struktur reinkommt, was ja auch gut ist mit Training zum Spiel fahren, zum Turnier fahren und wieder Training. Wenn man ja diesen, wenn man diesen Weg weit geht, ja, über Landesauswahl beispielsweise, und dann rutscht man ja automatisch in diese Strukturen rein. Genau das, was Marius sagt, die Lockerheit beibehalten, den Spaß, warum man das eigentlich überhaupt macht, warum man jeden darauf steht, das ist wichtig. Und eigentlich muss man auch ganz klar sagen, das glaube ich, wenn man so 13, 14 ist oder auch so diesen Weg geht, das möchte man vielleicht nicht hören und auch gar nicht wahrhaben, es kommen Tiefschläge, egal in welcher Form. Man steht mal nicht in der Aufstellung, man hat vielleicht mal eine Verletzung, dass man wenigstens bereit ist und weiß, so was kann kommen. Und dann auch gefestigt versuchen zu sein und nicht in Panik verfallen. Oft ist es auch so, ich habe auch viele gesehen, die mit sich selber dann zu kämpfen hatten, warum funktioniert mein Körper nicht, ja, und sauer auf sich selber wird, warum hält das verdammte Knie nicht. Dass man da ein bisschen zurück stritt und Marius hat das einfach toll gesagt. Fußball ist eine ziemlich geile Sache, aber nicht das Wichtigste. Also, dass man da ein bisschen diese Lockerheit behält. Dann sind wir wieder bei Plan A, den wir jetzt neuerdings Plan A nennen. Die Schulen nicht vergessen, aber da vor allem den Weg auch gehen. Also, wir würden ja wieder gehen. Also, was da auch auf höchstem Niveau, wenn man es schafft, auf seinem höchstem Niveau, Fußball mit Gleichgesinnten, die wirklich – es gibt es geiler als Mannschaftssport, wo man zusammen Siege feiern kann oder auch zusammen verlieren kann, je nachdem. Das lohnt sich und denen auf jeden Fall gehen, aber auch wissen, es gibt noch was anderes.
Ich bin sehr erleichtert, dass hier die 23- und 24-Jährigen sagen, nehmt die Schule ernst. Dann muss es nämlich keiner von uns alten Säcken sagen. Stefan, deine letzten Worte.
Ja, also, es ist, glaube ich, jetzt alles gesagt. Ja, also besser als Alex und Marius, kann ich es jetzt nicht mehr sagen, soll ich auch dazu sagen. Ich habe das nicht erlebt. Die beiden, die wissen, worum es geht, die wissen, was da Phase ist. Die haben alles mitgemacht, von oben bis unten. Und deswegen, ja, wie gesagt, es ist aus meiner Sicht, also wir könnten noch ewig wirklich sehr viel weiter reden. Es gibt noch viele, viele andere Aspekte, die wir auch schon alle heraus versucht haben, auszuarbeiten. Aber das würde mir als Schlusswort jetzt tatsächlich auch schon reihen.
Okay, dann lege ich dir als Schlusswort einfach in den Mund. Jungs und Mädchen da draußen, sporto fit ist der, ill shit. Dann kann man besser durchatmen. Es geht doch nichts um über Menthol auf der Brust. Das habe ich gelernt. Hat einer von uns hier in der Runde irgendwann mal Nasenpflaster getragen? Ich nicht. Ich war so kurz davor, aber ich hatte das Glück, dass es das bei uns halt auf dem Land nicht gab. Aber ich bin ja genau in dieser Phase mit dem Fußball sozialisiert worden. Mit den ganzen Lauteren, die da ihre Nasenpflaster getragen haben. Also ja, ich bin auch froh, dass es nicht geklappt hat. Also ich danke euch dreien sehr. Das war eine sehr interessante Sendung. Ich kann nur noch mal das Buch empfehlen von und über Marius von Cysewski und Alexander Schulte, die Jahrtausendtalente heißt es, wie zwei junge Fußballer ihren großen Traum lebten. 240 Seiten erschienen bei edelsports am 6. Mai. Also wenn ihr es euch jetzt besorgt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann seid ihr mit unter den ersten, die das lesen. Und das muss ja wohl das Ziel sein, immer unter den ersten zu sein. Das haben wir ja heute gelernt. Malius, Alex, ich danke euch beiden sehr für eure Zeit. Und ich hoffe irgendwie, dass wir uns auf jeden Fall nochmal hören im Rasenfunk. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das war hier nur eins von mehreren Tribünengesprächen zu diesem Thema.
Ja, sehr gerne. Danke für die Einladung.
Ja, das nächste Mal gibt es dann auch zwei funktionierende Kopfhörer. Ich verspreche es. Und danke an Stefan Rommel, der Ed Knall-Göber, auf Twitter mit seinem 22. Auftritt im Rasenfunk. Danke dir, lieber Stefan, für deine Zeit. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte empfehlt diese Folge weiter, empfehlt den Rasenfunk weiter und unterstützt den Rasenfunk, denn all das hier gibt es nur, weil ihr es finanziert. Ansonsten gäbe es so ein Medium wie den Rasenfunk nicht. Auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und auf rasenfunk.de findet ihr auch all die anderen Sendungen, die wir so produzieren. In diesem Sinne, das war Tribünengespräch Nr. 50. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Das war das Rasenfunk.